Jetzt kann ich dir sogar sagen, was für mich der Moment war, wo ich aufgehört habe mit Postbox. Vielleicht lässt sich das ja beheben, aber das war für mich leider das Ende. Und zwar also die Liste der Mails, also wo die Mails sozusagen mit ihren, in einer Tabelle untereinander sind durch eine schwarze Linie getrennt. Das ist so wie bei Eudora in den 90er Jahren.
Oh ja, da kommen Erinnerungen.
Ja sorry, I'm.
Die weitere Sendung verzögert sich um 30 Minuten.
Oh mein Gott! Wie der Chat schon gerade so schön meinte, mach den Affen weg.
Ein Klassiker.
Das ist ein, ist kein Affe, ne?
Lass uns Schubaka nachmachen.
Könnte mir das bei dir eigentlich ganz gut vorstellen.
Könnte dran arbeiten. Aber das ist kein Affe, das ist ein Wookie.
Mach den Wookie weg. Ja, hallo, hier ist Freak Show, 178. Einfach so zack direkt rein, ohne Ankündigung.
Und das erste Thema lautet?
Weiß nicht, wollen wir uns erst mal sagen, wer da ist? Clemens ist da.
Müssen wir uns schon erstmal vorstellen. Ich kenne ja die Leute schon gar nicht mehr.
Ach, nur komm. Ich war doch neulich schon mal hier. Ich musste da ein bisschen reisen. Ich hatte dienstlich zu tun auf Mallorca, als hier ja alle im Sumpf versunken sind.
Da gab es keine Tornaden.
Nein, nix, da gab es einfach nur geiles Wetter.
Hast du die Sandkorngrößenverteilung im Strand überprüft?
Nee, das war nicht am Strand, das war in der Mitte von der Insel, das war aber trotzdem ziemlich geil. Ich hab da ein bisschen weit gearbeitet und dann hab ich auf das Netz aufgepasst, während ich da am Pool in der Sonne lag, mit einem Drink in der Hand und einem grünen Plastikkrokodil, was ich sehr lieb gewonnen habe. Muss ich leider zurücklassen. Aber ich hab dann zwischendurch mir die Tweets angeguckt, wie denn hier Deutschland im Sumpf versinkt. Also du hast jetzt weniger witzig gemeint, jetzt bezüglich Süddeutschland, aber hier in Berlin hat es auch ordentlich geregnet.
Es gab Niederschlag.
Aber der Fahrer überschauber.
Aber auch heftig. Kurz, aber heftig.
Verstehe.
Der ein oder andere Blitz ist auch niedergegangen, aber nicht hier. Hier war es nur nass. Ja, Dennis kennt natürlich alle.
Weil der alte Streber ist immer da.
Nee, gar nicht. War ja auch zweimal nicht da, aber ist schon länger her.
Das bringt mich glatt auf den Punkt, auch mal so den aktuellen Teilnahmescore zu verlesen.
Eigentlich wär gar nicht interessant. Eigentlich müsste man das in Prozentzahlen ausdrücken. Von den Sendungen, zu denen man hätte da sein können. Weil Clemens war ja natürlich früher, hätte er ja auch nicht da sein können, weil er war ja noch nicht so weit.
Das ist richtig.
Deswegen eigentlich so ein Prozent von ab dann, ab wo man mitgemacht hat.
Das ist eigentlich der faire Score. Allerdings zählt auch das absolut, also sich hier n-hundertmal her zu bewegen, hier sich fette Pizza einzuschieben und sich mit Mate voll laufen zu lassen, ist natürlich auch schon ein Accomplishment. Nee, aber man muss dazu sagen, der ist schon eine Weile runter von der Mate, ne?
Ja, schon lange.
Das ist fairerweise.
Schmeckt mir nicht mehr so.
Aber an der Pizza partizipierst du immer noch?
Heute auch nicht zum Beispiel. Und ich hab Brötchen. Ich nehm oft Nudeln, weil Pizza das geht einfach nicht mehr. Das hat so nachgelassen. Und jetzt gerade, wenn wir gleich ein Thema draus machen, also dieses, jetzt ich muss jetzt das...
Wir müssen jetzt mal Huckel noch vorstellen, weil Huckel ist ja auch da.
Der kann sich gleich mit einklinken, weil der ist bestimmt meiner Meinung.
Und Rotti ist nicht da.
Genau.
Und Letty ist auch nicht da.
Aber diese Pizza liefert...
Tim ist da.
Diese Pizza Lieferdienste, das geht gar nicht mehr. Erstens ist gerade voll der Pizza-Delivery-Krieg hier. Wie heißen die? Fuduru? Nee, Delivery... Ist auch egal. Die ganzen Buden, ja, die kaufen sich alle gegenseitig auf. Das heißt, es gibt immer weniger Firmen. Da gibt's auch so einen Fachbegriff für, wie heißt das? Konsolidierung des Marktes oder so ein Scheiß. Und sollen sie ja machen, das sind ja Schnuppe, weil die Restaurants am Ende sind ja eigentlich die gleichen. Aber, dann gehen auch noch natürlich voll die Preise nach oben für nicht gerade Qualitäterzeugnisse, muss man jetzt wirklich sagen. Also Liefer-Pizza ist selbst von guten Läden eine gelieferte Pizza ist einfach nur noch die Hälfte wert, weil es halt wabbelig geworden ist. Und dann wollen jetzt bei Domino's zum Beispiel, die vorher noch Joey's hießen, haben wir ja bestimmt mitbekommen, bei Timme, ne?
Wir haben heute noch von Joey's geliefert bekommen.
Aber bei der Webseite kannst du bei Joey's gleich am Domino's weitergeliefert. Also das wurden ja gekauft. Jedenfalls sind die Preise ja erst mal auf irgendwie Richtung 11 Euro hochgeschossen für so eine mittlere Pizza.
Bei Joey's steht immer noch Joey's.
Haben sie das heuer gekauft?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab davon nichts mitbekommen.
Na ja, ich schon. Jedenfalls geht das alles gar nicht mehr und seitdem, ich boykottiere das gerade so ein bisschen.
Es ist auch Gerüchte heiber so, dass diese Lieferdienste auch nicht besonders nett sind zu den Restaurants.
Ich glaub, die Restaurants leiden noch am meisten. Und ich natürlich, weil das Essen ist scheiße.
Zum Beispiel dieses ganze Risiko, was da dran ist, tragen allein diese Restaurants, ne? Das heißt, wenn da ein Trop anruft und eine Pizza hinbestellt, an einer Adresse, die nicht seine ist, und die Leute sagen, wie, wat, wie, geh weg, dann zahlt das Restaurante. Ich glaube, sie müssen trotzdem den Lieferdienst bezahlen. Das heißt, das komplette Risiko für solche Sachen liegt alles bei den Restaurants usw. Also das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, Kapitalismus, wie er im Buche steht, aber ist halt auf der Ferne-Skala nicht so weit oben.
Wir hatten ja im Club schon öfter mal so eine Großbestellung. Wenn dann mal die Bude voll ist und dann mal so 10, 15 Leute essen wollen, dann haben wir auch schon mal so Pizza-Bestellungen über 100 Euro. Und teilweise haben wir dann auch schon so Angebote von kleineren Restaurants, jetzt nicht diese großen Ketten hier oder Filialen, sondern so kleinere Buden, die dann sagen, ey Jungs, hier am besten ruft man bei uns direkt an, ohne hier diese Pizza.de-Nummern. Und dann ist besser für die, ist auch besser für uns, meinen sie, weil dann kommen nämlich so ein bisschen extra Getränke mit und so. Wahrscheinlich darf man jetzt keine Restaurant-Namen kennen, weil sie wahrscheinlich sonst gegen ihre Verträge da verstoßen und so, aber das rächt sich, weil es werden die Restaurants natürlich jetzt immer mehr machen, dass sie sagen, ey, hier ruft er mal direkt an, wenn er uns eine Weile kennt.
Das ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert wie immer, wie man da reinruft.
Die machen sich gerade gegenseitig kaputt, also so richtig schick finde ich das nicht.
Ich bestelle keine Pizza, außer hier, wo ich bestellen lasse. Also insofern habe ich das Problem gar nicht, weil im schönen Kreuzberg gibt es genug leckeres Essen.
Das stimmt.
Würde es ja hier auch geben, Hucke, wenn du mit deinem fucking Auto, was du ja manchmal machst jetzt gerade, ich will es ja wieder mit Moppeta, sehr gut, ich finde das ja gut, aber wenn wir im Winter mal öfter hier bei unserem Lieblingspizza laden und wir selber holen würden, haben wir aber nicht gemacht diesen Winter.
Muss man sich aber kümmern.
Nächsten Winter. Na toll.
Wir könnten ja auch mal rausgehen. Hab ich schon mal vorgeschlagen, das war irgendwie mal so eine Freak Show und Tour. Wir können ja einfach mal durch den Kiez laufen. Wir haben die technischen Voraussetzungen dafür. Auf dem Camp waren wir wieder drinnen, da waren wir unterm Zelt und mit irgendwelchen, nee, nie so draußen. Wir laufen ja durch den Kiez, Leute fragen sich, nee, fragst du dich ja in Berlin keine, da kannst du mit Kopfhörer auf dem Kopf rumlaufen, ob ein Mikrofon dran ist und sich gegenseitig voll quaken. Das fällt gar nicht auf.
Letztens hab ich einen die Prenzlauallee hochlaufen sehen mit so einem Röhrenmonitor auf dem Kopf. Hat sich aber auch keiner drum geschält, also so, ah ja, okay.
So den Kopf eben...
Jaja, also war wahrscheinlich nichts mehr drin, aber er hatte so original so ein schönes, würde ich sagen, war bestimmt so 15 Zoll mindestens, wenn ich mit dem Briefe...
Ja, das kann man ja mal so machen, Experimental. Gerade wenn jetzt das Wetter schön ist.
Naja, wenn man... Also das ist ja so ein alter Traum von mir. Ich hoffe ja, dass in dem tollen Studio Link-Projekt sich unter Umständen etwas abzeichnet, womit man das vielleicht machen könnte, dass man halt tatsächlich so mit mehreren Leuten mit Headset auf sehr mobil unterwegs sein kann. Also möglichst wenig.
Können wir mal einen iOS-Klient bauen?
Bitte?
Können wir mal einen iOS-Klient bauen, dann kann man das schon mal auf so ein portables Gerät drauf tun.
Ja, das ist auch...
Dann kommt ein Akku-Pack unten dran und dann eine schöne billige LTE-Karte von Dollar Repair Provider und ab dafür.
Mit dem Grad des WLAN in Berlin geht das doch auch.
Das müssen wir echt auf die Liste setzen. Aber über LTE, das wäre dann auch machbar. Aber wenn man sozusagen gemeinsam umherläuft, dann würde ja auch ein lokales Laden, also ein WLAN, reichen. Und das könnte man halt... Du meinst jetzt, um streamen zu können?
Ja, um live. Du willst ja eine Live-Show machen. Du willst ja nicht einfach durch die Gegend rennen, wie für eine Banzer oder so, hinter die Aufzeichnung raus schließen, sondern Live-Freak Show, so beim durch die Gegend tapern. Ja, das kann man... Wir sind doch offen hier für Experimente.
Genau, aber vor allem geht es ja erstmal darum, die Kommunikation untereinander möglichst latenzfrei hinzubekommen. Und da wäre ja diese kleine Studio Link-Box eigentlich prädestiniert.
Musst du dann nicht nochmal wieder eine extra Box mit mir rumschleppen? Ich mach dir einen lokalen WLAN auf, den ich auf dem Rucksack durch die Gegend trage. Dann könnt ihr euch alle einbuchen und dann machen wir Studio Link über WLAN von den iPhones.
Ja, aber du musst ja von deinem Headset überhaupt erstmal zu dem zentralen Mischer kommen. Und da ist ja diese Studio Link-Box eigentlich viel besser als ein iOS-Teil. Na, dedicated hardware haut da deutlich besser hin.
Auf so einem Telefon hast du dann wieder Notifications und Anrufe.
Okay, man könnte das Ding theoretisch im Airplane-Modus machen.
Dann mit wem redest du denn?
Na, WLAN geht ja dann noch.
Na gut, dann kriegste wieder E-Mails.
Ja, ja, nur Internet muss man ja nicht unbedingt haben. Nur WLAN, also erstmal nur lokales...
Ja, man könnte ein Lokal halt WLAN bauen, dass die alle auf dem Bischer ankommen und dann nur den Stream nach draußen lassen und so. Wir können jetzt mit der Studio Link-Box rumlaufen, ist ja egal, du brauchst eh ein Powerpack.
Genau, du brauchst Powerpack, du brauchst einen Beagle-Bone und du brauchst einen Kopfhörer-Verstärker und so. Vielleicht hat eine zukünftige Version das auch gleich mit drin. Beziehungsweise mit einem USB-Headset könnte man das auch machen, aber das ist natürlich nicht das, was man benutzen will.
Aber du hast ja so USB-Dongle, die dann in deinem Kopfhörer drauf passen, mit inklusive Phantom-Speisen und so.
Ja, aber dann fügst du halt auch schon wieder so Grundlatenz mit ein... Also, es gibt viele Wege für nach Rom.
Keiner wieder raus.
Absehbar, dass das irgendwie hinhaut. Apple hat jetzt auch irgendein beklopptes Patent von Apple ausgegraben worden, wo sie so Peer-to-Peer-Conferencing mit ihr an die Beise zeigen. Hey, wir lassen uns einfach lang das Kabel nehmen. Ja, aber Kabel ist halt blöd. Weil dann hängst du halt aneinander, dann können keine...
Das ist doch auch ein gruppendynamisches Erlebnis.
Laufen wir durch die Gegend wie ein Bier-Bike, das geht nicht. Ja, das ist es doch. Stimmt, dann müssen wir den Scheiß nicht schleppen. Dann machen wir die ganze Onig hinten drauf mit einer fetten Autobatterie und fahren mit dem Scheiß-Bike durch die Stadt. Können wir auch machen.
Haben die in der Mitte so einen Tisch?
Ich setz mich auf so ein Ding nicht rauf, kannste voll vergessen.
Dann ziehen wir dich im Anhänger.
Dann gehst du in die Mitte, das geht nicht.
Dann fahren wir durch Marzahn.
Oder eine Dampferfahrt.
Dampferfahrt wär auch cool. Dann kann man auch schön am Tisch sitzen, schöne Sachen sehen.
Und dann gleich mit Live-Publikum.
Das ist auch mal eine Idee. Dampferfahrt, das können wir machen.
Draußen muss ich bewegen. Ich checke vorher die Fahrt ab, ob es überall ordentliche LTE-Abdeckungen gibt von zwei Providern. Dann mache ich dir deinen ordentlichen stabilen Link hin und dann machen wir auf der Dampferfahrt was. Ey, hallo! Ihr müsst noch was gehen, ihr müsst nicht aus dieser Stinke Boote nehmen raus.
Okay, na, das wird teuer.
Dampferfahrt ist nicht teuer.
Kann man machen. Nein, Teilnehmer. Na, Dampferfahrt? Na wieso? Ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr so ein komplettes Schiffchen mietet.
Nö, kommt drauf an, wie groß das ist. Hab ich schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Hab ich auch für Geburtstage schon gemacht.
Größenordnung?
Ja, das war dann halt so ein 20, 25er Schiffchen oder so was. Wenn du natürlich jetzt so einen fetten Wannsee-Dampfer für 300 Leute nehmen willst, ein Ausflugsding, die wollen da schon ein bisschen mehr Partie für haben. So berühmt sind wir dann doch wieder nicht. Aber wir könnten so ein kleines Schiffchen und damit hier so einen Landwehrkanal und Spree lang eiern. Das gibt so schöne Rundtouren. Und wenn die fertig ist, dann sind wir auch fertig. Zum Beispiel.
Nun sagen die Leute, dass ich jetzt übersteuern würde oder schreien würde, hast du vielleicht statt dem Clemens mehr Gain mir vielleicht etwas zu viel Gain spendiert?
Gain?
Du hast ein bisschen mehr Gain, ja. Aber ich hab das nicht eben gerade. Das sollte aber keinen Unterschied machen.
Leute, wir wissen es nicht.
Aber das ist doch mal eine schöne Idee. Das ist doch mal eine Idee, die man mal in seinem Herzen bewegen kann.
Das können wir machen. Wir bewegen die Idee in unserem Herzen.
Und zwischen der linken und der rechten Hirnhälfte.
Ja, Live-Podkrasse. Da müssen aber dann auch alle kommen.
Ach so.
Ja, für Dampferfahrt würde ich mich nicht lumpen lassen.
Aha, dann doch.
Dampferfahrt?
Auch wenn ich da so jetzt eine Latente...
Kannst du, wie gesagt, städtisch machen, hier so Kreuzbergmitte und so da rum eiern. Kannst aber auch ein Spießig machen und dann hinten so potzamen. Im Plinasee und so weiter, sind immer auch ganz schick da hinten.
Müggelsee.
Im Müggelsee können wir auch machen. Aber der Müggelsee ist nicht so weit, das reicht nicht für eine Freak Show. Der eiert da seine drei Landestellen an und dann wartet. Selbst wenn er noch mal nach Köpenick-Mitte fährt, da wartet er. Also wenn, dann musst du schon so eine Tour nehmen, die entweder ein bisschen... Von Müggelsee bis Spandau.
Schauen wir schon.
Kriegen wir werden.
Gibt es denn auch als Solarboot?
Allerdings dann natürlich nicht zu unserer Sendezeit üblicherweise so gut. Das müsste ja schon eher tagsüber sein.
Ach du meinst, wir machen den ersten komplett solar...
Betriebenen Podcast?
Betriebenen, erzeugten, sendenden Podcast?
Vormsee. Das ist jetzt besonders... Besonders environmentally friendly.
Podcast, jetzt auch CO2 in der Sprache.
Dann springt deine Werbekunden voll drauf an.
Außer der Dampfer.
Aber die Metaebene fährt eher auf Solarstrom, von daher...
Die Metaebene fährt auf Solarstrom?
Ja, ich kauf bei so einem 100% Solarprovider meinen Strom. Das ist hoffentlich doch schwer, dass er das tut.
Doch, da wird es sehr... Ja, klar, dass du die Elektronenlöcher nicht nachzählen kannst, wo sie herkommen. Aber das wird in der Tat sehr, sehr scharf reguliert. Ich hatte jetzt die Veranstaltung, da letztes Jahr auch auf Malle, war eine Firma, die auch im Energiesektor tätig ist. Und da gab es auch Vorträge von Leuten, die sich da gerade mit der Regulierung befassen. Also wer passt jetzt eigentlich darauf auf, dass das auch hinhaut? Das war jetzt konkret dieser Vortrag im Gasmarkt, der sagt, das funktioniert im Elektromarkt ganz genauso. Das sind doch dieselben Behörden. Wenn jemand da, keine Ahnung, 7.500, oder so und so viele 1000 Kilowattstunden Solarstrom abnimmt, dann muss da für jemand anders dieselbe Menge Solarstrom eingespeist haben. Sonst gibt es auf die 12. Und noch geht das. Gibt es zwar jetzt eine tolle neue europäische Behörde, die sie jetzt in Ljubljana eingerichtet haben, die jetzt aufpassen soll, dass da doch alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht, aber die gehen eher dahin, dass da keine Insider-Geschäfte stattfinden. Aber ansonsten gibt es da eine Behörde, die aufpasst. Also wie gesagt, es ist doch beim Gas. Beim Gas hast du das selbe Thema, gibt es ja Biogas. Und wenn du jetzt Gasabnehmer bist, also Haushaltsgas, klar, kriegst du jetzt immer das selbe Haushaltsgas, was in deinem Brenner in der Küche abgeht. Aber dieselbe Energiemenge, die du da verbrauchst und die dir abgerechnet wird, muss irgendjemand anders als Biogas einspeisen.
So gehört sich das auch, sag ich mal.
So würde man sich das auch vorstellen.
So würde man sich das auch vorstellen, und so ist es dann auch. Ja, was gehört sich denn noch?
Ja, also wir beobachten mit großer Dogmas.
Das ist jetzt zum nächsten Dienstag?
13.
Kann, ist das immer so?
Es ist auf jeden Fall die Woche.
Am 13.6.
Wo ist jetzt unser Mac-Developer, wenn wir ihn mehr brauchen?
Wieso, wozu brauchen wir den jetzt gerade?
Na, der wüsste so was.
Den brauchen wir erst zur Nachbesprechung. 19 Uhr am Montag, den 13. rauscht der Strom hier. Da gibt es eine Schlüsselnote. Zwei Stunden haben sie angesetzt. Die werden sie wahrscheinlich auch einhalten, nehme ich mal an. Das können sie ja ganz gut. Vielleicht haben sie so einen stabilen Strom. Ja, und weiß nicht, sieht nicht so spannend aus, oder? Also man weiß es nicht. Im Bereich Software halten sie ja in der Regel immer ganz gut die Klappe, weil da haben sie nicht diese ganzen Industrieleaks. Aber die Industrieleaks, die jetzt so gerade da sind, also bevor wir jetzt über die WWDC reden, da kann man nicht viel drüber reden. Aber das mit diesem MacBook Pro, das ist schon... Ich hatte ja letzte Woche noch so in meinem Jugendlichen Leichtsinn und in meinem Grundoptimismus so ein OLED-Keyboard herbeifabuliert, was ich ganz toll fände und auch den richtigen Weg fände.
Und dann war plötzlich die Escape-Taste drauf.
Und dann kam dieser... Wir hatten ja glaube ich letztes Mal nur über das Gerücht gesprochen und dann kam dieses Foto von diesem Gehäuse-Teil. Was nahelegt, dass ein MacBook Pro, ob das mir nächste Woche vorgestellt wird oder nicht, wissen wir nicht. Ich vermute mal nicht. Aber worauf es unter Umständen hinausläuft, ist halt ein MacBook Pro mit vier USB-C Ports.
Oder zwei USB-C und zwei Thunderbolts.
Ja, USB-C beherbergt jetzt auch Thunderbolt. Also der separate Thunderbolt-Stecker wird jetzt auch entfallen, weil Thunderbolt 3 geht halt auch über ein USB-C-Port.
Was heißt aber nicht, dass alle vier Ports wirklich Thunderbolt 3 sind?
Das heißt das nicht unbedingt. Das könnte auch sein, dass es nur zwei sind. Könnte aber auch anders sein. Also das weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt... Jetzt sind viele Details, die ich mich jetzt nicht aufreiben möchte.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass Apple auch die Perspektive von Apple einnimmt, würde ich sagen, alle vier Ports müssen identisch bestückt sein. Also es muss alles über alles gehen, weil dieses Experience mit Stecks ran und geht nicht, das können die sich eigentlich gar nicht erlauben. Und letzten Endes sehe ich da auch nicht so ein großes Problem, weil am Ende müssen sie halt nur irgendwie die Pins da auseinanderklammbüttert bekommen. Also die müssen sie eh alle reinführen, die müssen eh alle Strom führen, dann können sie darüber auch den Kram machen. Ja und dann hätte man im Prinzip, was man hat. Also man hätte sozusagen nur noch ein Dungelformat. Aber man bräuchte es dann sozusagen für alles, was nicht mit USB-C selber daherkommt.
Was ungefähr alles ist. Also echt irgendwie diese IO. Podcast-Tierung, die da jedes Release von diesem MacBook Pro in Anführungsstrichen fortschreitet, die finde ich wirklich total mega abtörend. Also ich habe ja nach wie vor meinen 2010 MacBook Pro mit Ethernet, Firewire 800, USB 3, Thunderbolt und…
Nee, nee, nee, 2010er hat kein USB 3.
2012.
Ich habe einen 10er und der hat leider keinen USB 3.
Ja, ich habe USB 3, das ist ja die letzte Serie von den alten Geräten mit Almen drin. Und irgendwie, die einzige Schnittstelle, die ich gerne wieder abgebe, ist dieser SD-Karten-Rieder. Denen brauche ich wirklich so gut wie nie. Aber zweimal USB, also… Ja, aber…
Geht aber auch.
Wie zweimal?
Also ich habe zwei USB 3-Ports. Und irgendwie, wenn die jetzt wirklich alles nur noch USB-C machen, also ich habe kein Gerät, was ich da direkt anschließen kann, und habe dann hier so ein Dongel-Zoo irgendwie an meinem Rechner dran oder was?
Ja, aber so war es doch damals beim iMac auch, als das Ding nur USB hatte.
Ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, aber da hat die ganze Welt USB gesprochen, nur Apple nicht. Also der Trend von Apple war ja…
Was war denn, welche Welt hat USB gesprochen? Als der iMac rauskam mit USB, da hat diese Welt noch überhaupt nicht USB gesprochen.
Ja, doch, da gab es schon USB.
Von welchem redest du jetzt?
Da gab es doch keine PC-USB-Emozen?
Nein. Also vielleicht wurden welche hergestellt.
Die PC-Maserboards hatten alle schon USB, weil Internet hat gesagt, mach das mal da drauf und so, aber die haben alle weiter PS2 benutzt und Apple hat dann USB rausgebracht und gesagt, wir bringen es raus, aber wir nutzen es auch und dann kamen die Apple-Tastatur, die Apple-Maus und so weiter und dann ging das so langsam los.
Dann wäre wir auch ohne Apple wahrscheinlich losgegangen.
Die Boards haben doch heute noch...
Damals hat doch Apple noch keine so große Rolle gespielt, dass jetzt irgendwie plötzlich alle schreien, oh mein Gott, wir müssen USB-Peripherie rausbringen.
Nee, hatten sie ja auch nicht, deswegen. Hatte keinen interessiert. Erstmal nur Apple.
Ja, aber trotzdem hat der iMac, hat den USB-Markt im Prinzip erstens Rollen gebracht.
Na ja, finde ich eine steile These, aber nehme ich mal so hin.
Das war so.
Die haben doch heute noch VGA und PS2-Boards an ihren Boards. Na ist doch so.
Ist doch so!
Ja, das kann ja nun auch nicht die Zukunft sein.
Nee, das kann auf jeden Fall nicht die Zukunft sein. Aber die Peripherie-Realität da draußen ist ja jetzt schon einigermaßen eindeutig.
Na gut, aber mal ehrlich.
Ich weiß ja, was du meinst. Das Problem ist, dass du für jeden Scheiß USB-2-Stecker jetzt einen Dongle brauchst. Das, würde ich sagen, ist die eigentliche Einschränkung.
Für mich ist es eine Einschränkung.
Hast du da auch HDMI-Ausgang dran?
Nee, aber...
Ja gut, das ist ja im Prinzip dieselbe Soße. Thunderbolt ist, wenn ich hier Ethernet anschließen will, an meinen Rechner muss ich auch über den Thunderbolt fortgehen.
Ja, für mich nicht. Also für mich ist es halt der krasse Schritt in die Dongle-Welt, weil alles, was ich hier so noch nativ in Anführungsstrichen anschließe, muss ich verdongeln. Und ich hab Ethernet dran, ich hab zweimal USB dran, ich hab Firewire dran und wenn ich mir jetzt...
Jetzt kann man ja mal sagen, wir hoffen denn, dass wenn Apple diesen Schritt mal geht, dass sie vielleicht mal selber auf die Idee kommen, eine ordentliche Docking-Station zu bauen. Statt das wieder der Zuliefererindustrie zu erlassen, dann wär das ja okay. Weil ich find das auch okay. Wenn ich das Ding abdocke, brauche ich den ganzen Scheiß in der Regel nicht. Vielleicht, okay, das Ethernet-Ding gelingt nicht, aber da legen wir noch einen Dongle mit in die Tüte, da hab ich jetzt kein Problem mit. Aber du hast schon recht, wenn man das Ding immer hin und her wechselt und dann an den Arbeitsplatz geht und dann erst mal so dräufig Kabel da reinstecken muss, das ist natürlich schon so meh.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, also Arbeitsplatz ist halt dann auch Docking Station. Also wenn du wirklich einen festen Ort hast, wo du alles anschließt, dann kannst du das halt problemlos mit so einer USB-C Docking Station machen, die dann alle Legacy Ports auf einmal hat und die auch schon fest verkauft sind.
Oder, so wie sie es ja schon gemacht haben, dass sie den Bildschirm, das ist ein Apple Display, quasi als Docking Station machen. Da kommt dann auch Power gleich mit raus und das Ding hat hinten nicht dran.
Wenn die irgendwann mal wieder ein Bildschirm überhaupt rausbringen. Ich meine, die haben das seit wann nicht mehr aktualisiert? 3, 4 Jahre?
Ja, aber das letzte hatte das. Mit USB-C kommt sogar noch der Power, weil bei dem letzten hast du ja dieses Mini Display Port Thunderbolt-Ding da drin gehabt. Da musstest du aber noch so ein separates Power-Käbelchen weiter mitkommen, ohne anplanken. War jetzt kein Drama, aber es sind 2 Kabel. Und wenn sie das jetzt alle über USB-C machen, inklusive Power und das Display als Docking-Station herhält, dann find ich das valide. Da kann ich mir nämlich mit leben, dass ich meinen Laptop auf den Tisch pack und ein Kabel reinstecke, weil das machen die mich sowieso immer. Das ist normalerweise das Power-Kabel. Und wenn ich jetzt stattdessen USB-C-Kabel mit Power da reinstecke und alles andere hinten an der Glotze dranhängt, dann mach ich das voll.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein ganz brauchbarer Use-Case. Und ich denke, so denkt Apple da auch drüber nach.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir die IOS-Schnittstellen-Geschichte von Apple angucke und was die so für Peripherie dafür raushauen, dann bin ich davon halt noch nicht so überzeugt. Also ich will mir jetzt nicht irgendwie von Apple ein 900-Euro-Display kaufen, nur damit ich irgendwie da die tolle Interoperabilität bekomme und die ganzen Thunderbolt-Docs, die es halt da gibt, die Preise sind halt auch irgendwie echt vom anderen Stern. Also nur weil ich USB 2 habe, will ich jetzt mir nicht einen Doc für 350 Euro kaufen müssen irgendwie. Das ist schon echt mies. Und noch dazu diese Dongles, die Apple jetzt verkauft. Also wenn man die nicht anfasst und nur auf dem Tisch liegen lässt, super. Aber wie viel von diesen komischen Adaptern davon Apple mir auch schon kaputt gegangen sind in genau den falschen Situationen, das ist halt auch nicht so feierlich.
Mir werden die immer nur geklaut, also gänsefüßchen geklaut. Kann ich mal kurz haben, bring ich die auch persönlich wieder.
Ja, und die, die einigermaßen bezahlbar sind, die haben jetzt zum Beispiel keinen Firewire, das ist halt auch wieder...
Und wenn du das haben willst, ich meine Thunderbolt Dock hat halt auch Thunderbolt Ausgänge und da kannst du dann halt auch wieder...
Ja, und dann noch einen Adapter und noch einen Dongle.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist doch ein erstrebenswertes Ziel, diesen ganzen multiplen Stecker-Scheiß.
Das ist eine Utopie. Das ist ein feuchter Traum, der nicht in die Realität umgesetzt werden wird.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen, weil...
Doch, aber das kostet halt ein Geld. Das ist ein teurer feuchter Traum.
Ja gut, aber USB-C, guck mal, was das Ding jetzt alles macht. Es macht Strom, es macht USB.
Macht das denn wirklich genug Strom für einen MacBook Pro? Nicht hier für so eine Flachkröte da, sondern für einen echten MacBook Pro?
Soweit ich weiß ja, USB, ich kann dir grad die Zahl nicht sagen, aber da kommt eine Menge Wumms raus.
Weil normalerweise hast du ja an so einem MacBook Pro, ich hab an meinem MacBook Pro immer noch keine Ahnung, 75 oder 85 Watt Netzteil. Ich hab lange keinen Pro mehr gekauft, um da zu sein seit sechs Jahren.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wie die Spezifikation ist, Strom, 100 Watt.
100 Watt? Okay, da geht noch was.
Und also Strom, USB, Bildschirm, also alles, was so Digital Pixel ist. Ich hab jetzt, beim Freund hab ich gesehen, ein MacBook, also dieses MacBook mit einem Port MacBook.
Mit Uno Pro.
Mit einem Kabel, was dann in so einen großen, was war das, Samsung 4K Fernseher reinging. Das war irgendwie schon irgendwie auch geil.
Wie ist denn der Stecker? Wie fühlt der sich denn so an?
Ich hab mit dem noch nicht viel gesteckt. Der ist halt, naja, ist halt nicht Lightning. Aber man muss zumindest nicht gucken, wie rum man ihn reinsteckt.
Das ist echt eins der kleinsten Probleme.
Na gut, den steckst du halt rein und dann ist er halt drin. Also schlechter als dieses Thunderbolt-Kabel kann es nicht sein.
Das ist nämlich auch total der Scheiß, dieses Thunderbolt, weil diese Stecker verbiegen sich, halt wenn da nur ein bisschen mechanische Belastung drauf ist.
Ja, aber das ist bei den Thunderbolt, bei den USB-C-Kabeln, so wie ich das bisher gesehen hab, ich hab da noch nicht so ein Ding gesehen, was zwei Zentimeter aus dem Rechner rausragt. Das ist ja wie so diesen Apple-Pen da irgendwie in sein iPad reinstecken. Also das wäre, also Thunderbolt, dem Stecker, weine ich keine Träne nach. Wenn der jetzt in USB-C verschmilzt, sag ich hurra, danke, war viel zu lange auf dem Markt, hätte man ja auch gleich machen können. Hat man aber nicht.
Naja, musst aber auch erstmal alles entwickeln.
Also wenn man diesem Gehäuse-Snapshot da glauben darf, ist halt die einzige Schnittstelle, die sie noch drin haben, die nicht USB-C ist, ist Kopfhöreranschluss.
Und gibt es noch einen Eingang?
Naja, der Kopfhöreranschluss hat ja auch einen Mikrofon-Eingang.
Also keinen normalen Line-In?
Den Line-In hat doch seit 30 Jahren keiner mehr benutzt. Ich hab den noch, ich hab sogar noch so einen Optischen. Wenn du da reinguckst, dann grinst der dich noch rot an.
Ich bitte dich, Line-In im Laptop.
Also nicht der Line-In.
Also ich meine, das willst du auch nicht benutzen. Das war irgendwann mal vielleicht ganz praktisch.
Vielleicht nicht Audio-Interfaces.
Vor allem, du hast da so viel Störstrahlung an der Stelle. Also da kriegst du einfach kein ordentliches Audiosignal rein.
Ich bin Fan von Laptop mit Ports.
Mit vielen Löchern.
Und halt nicht Dongles.
Ja gut, aber der hat ja vier Ports.
Und Dongle Ports.
Na, er hat nur dann Dongle Ports, wenn deine Peripherie noch nicht das Upgrade gemacht hat.
Ja, was die nächsten drei Jahre der Fall sein wird.
Vielleicht auch noch länger, aber ich meine, wenn man nicht damit anfängt, dann hört es ja nie auf.
Die machen das doch nur, damit das Ding schmaler wird, was mich zum Beispiel auch interessiert.
Ja, das dringt mich auch ein bisschen auf.
Ich finde das MacBook Pro, ich, für mich war bisher ein MacBook Pro keine Wahl, weil es zu groß war, ganz ehrlich.
Zu groß wegen zu dick oder wegen zu groß?
Zu schwer, zu dick, zu alles.
Zu alles.
Ich weiß, dass es auch schlanker geworden ist, aber mein R ist nach wie vor für mich die Ultima Ratio.
Ja, das kann ja auch gerne eher bleiben. Und dann machen sie einen so einen Boliden. Ja, so ein 15 Zoll Schiff. So, mit allem dran und drin.
Jetzt sind es 6 USB-C-Forts. Was mich viel eher anfängt, ist, dass jetzt wieder Design-Diskussionen losgehen. Gerade gestern wieder auf Ars Technica oder so, da haben wir ja auch so eine Mac-Abteilung. Und hin und her, ja, und dann könnte man den, und wenn der Port dahin rutscht, könnte man ja vorne noch irgendwie ein hundertstel Zoll abschleifen und so, ja, so ein Scheiß. Ich denke mir immer, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich mit Funktionalität? Wir warten jetzt alle, alle, warten wir da drauf, dass da endlich mal ein fucking LTE-Modem drin ist. Und zwar seit wie vielen Jahren?
Zwischenapplaus.
Doch ich schon, ich muss mich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich benutze seitdem jetzt LTE auch in Deutschland verfügbare und bezahlbare geworden ist, was ja zwar noch nicht so lange her ist, aber doch schon eine Weile, benutze ich viel, viel lieber meine LTE, anstatt mich irgendwie mit komischen freien WLANs rumzuärgern, die eben nicht frei sind und dann irgendwie portal lock in und langsam und scheiße und nerv. Und wenn ich mit meinem iPhone 6S oder so, da habe ich super LTE-Download-Raten und vor allen Dingen Upload-Raten und so was. Die hätte ich jetzt halt auch gerne im Rechner. Und was spricht jetzt eigentlich dagegen, dass ich da endlich mal eine SIM-Karte einbaue? Nix, genau. Das ist auch was für Profis, auch was für Leute, auch für die gehobene Preisklasse, für die sich Apple immer irgendwie zuständig sieht. Ist auch inzwischen, auch die Roaming ist auch kein Thema mehr. Also ich benutze dort auf meinem Telefon deutlich mehr LTE als WLAN. Ob die sie natürlich von zu Hause, ist klar. Aber wenn ich on the road bin, ärgere ich mich nicht mehr rum mit fremden Leuten WLANs.
Das sehe ich genauso. Also wenn es da ist, klar. Also WLAN ist halt so voll weg. Und ja, bin ich ganz bei dir. Und ich finde auch LTE muss da rein. Ich schätze mal, sie werden kein Modell machen, wo man wirklich noch eine SIM-Karte reinschiebt. Also wie das noch beim Telefon ist, sondern halt eher so eine...
Wo sie genau da am Rechner noch den Platz dafür hätten. So ein Download-SIM-Karte halt. Mir auch egal. Ich möchte das gerne benutzen. Und jetzt kommt mir nicht mehr, den kennt der mit dem iPhone-Tether an. Nee, kann ich nicht, weil dann ist meine Batterie schneller leer, als ich bla sagen kann. Das geht gar nicht. Deswegen möchte ich das gerne schön in meinem Laptop drin haben und unkompliziert, ohne dass ich extra drauf... Weißt du, so aufklappigen.
Extrem agile aufklappigen und so.
Genau. Wie wir jetzt so vom WLAN gewohnt sind, du klappst das Ding auf und dann geht es los. Ohne dass ich irgendwie rumtessern muss und so ein Scheiß. Und sagen wir mal so, jetzt kann man ja sagen, ist ja amerikanischer Markt und bla. Aber selbst in Amerika gibt es jetzt sowas. Und was für mich das führendste Argument ist, wenn ich auch sonst immer die PC-User alle, wenn die mich so mitleidig angucken, trotz meines sechs Jahre alten Macs, aber da haben sie alle einfach jeder Scheiß Laptop, der draußen rumwandt, der jetzt vielleicht nicht von Aldi ist oder so, hat inzwischen unten Scheiß Sim-Karten-Slot drin. Manchmal noch für 3G und so was, schön, gut. Aber die meisten neuen mit LTE und so was. Also da ist die PC-Industrie, so die Lenovo dieser Welt längst an der Apple-Truppe vorbeigezogen. Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass Apple jetzt sagt, oh, da müssen wir aber schwierig Technologie einkaufen. Ich meine, die bauen verfickte Telefone und iPads, die da drin haben. Die können einfach denselben Chipset sich von ihrer selbst designten Truppe da mal auf den MacBook Pro drauflöten lassen und gut ist. Das müssen sie jetzt nicht mal schwer einkaufen irgendwo, das Know-How. Das finde ich so ein bisschen ärgerlich.
Nochmal kurze Frage, dieses, wenn man jetzt ein Thunderbolt-Gerät hat, gibt es dann Thunderbolt auf USB-C-Kabel oder muss man dongeln? Also ist das quasi einfach so transparent?
Das wird es sicherlich auch geben dann. Guck dir mal an, als Apple mit der Thunderbolt nochmal losgelegt hat, haben sie auch erst mal so, hier ist der Thunderbolt nach Firewire 800 Adapter, hier ist der Thunderbolt nach Gigabit, die waren gar nicht so teuer. Die haben, keine Ahnung, 20 oder 30 Euro gekostet. Komm, wenn du dir einen MacBook Pro kaufst für 2000 Euro, dann kannst du uns sagen, ich brauch jetzt unbedingt noch für meine gammlige, alte Firewire 800 Platte von 1874, brauch ich noch so einen scheiß Adapter, dann kannst du die 25 Öcken auch noch auf den Tisch legen.
Ja, aber auch für Audio, ich meine...
Nee, die Frage war jetzt gar nicht, wie damals von Firewire 800 auf 400 einfach so ein Kabel funktioniert hat, wenn das jetzt im Prinzip jetzt Thunderbolt inkludiert, dann gibt es vielleicht auch einfach einen USB-C auf deiner Urkabel?
Also bei eigenen und vor allem stationären Geräten sehe ich dieses Argument nicht. Weil da kannst du einfach deine Geräte dongeln und dann kommt da nur noch USB-C raus. So. Du musst ja nicht unbedingt auf deiner Rechnerseite da tief rangehen.
Was war das Argument dafür nochmal? Also alles jetzt zu den port-vereinheitlichen? Und dongeln?
Ja, dass mittelfristig natürlich irgendwann diese ganzen Geräte, die heute noch mit dieser oder jener Schiffsstelle rauskommen. Naja, aber guck mal, wenn du heute ein Gerät, hier zum Beispiel dieses, kann ich nachher eh nochmal erzählen, hier dieses Moto Thunderbolt-Audio-Device, da ist halt ein USB-Port, da ist ein Thunderbolt-Port, so, hm hm hm, wäre auch nur noch ein Port. Also macht auch diese Endgeräte leichter. Und dann switchst du dann halt einfach den Modus um, den du brauchst. Und du kannst über dasselbe Kabel zur Not eben auch noch einen Bildschirm ansteuern, etc. und Strom liefern. Das ist schon geil.
Sagt der Mann, der hier ein Mac Pro alter Bauert unterm Tisch hat und mit Ethernet sein Audiointerface angeschlossen hat.
Naja, ich mein, das war vor 5 Jahren, weil das halt die Zukunft war. Und von daher, das war im Prinzip auch schon so alles über ein Kabel Vision.
War eine andere Frage von einem Opa, der immer noch in der USB-2-Welt lebt. Nee, 2. Nein, nein, MacBook Pro 2010, USB 2. Schlimme Steinzeit. Sag doch mal, wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus? Gibt es denn schon USB-C-Switches? Ich wage jetzt gar nicht hub zu sagen, aber so... Ja, ist aber jetzt nicht die Frage. Wenn jetzt USB-C der neue heiße Scheiße ist und Apple sich entscheidet, mir davon N-Ports zu geben, lasst es doch 4 sein, ja, aber sie haben ja in den anderen Dingern vielleicht bloß einen Port. Und jetzt möchte ich mir vielleicht doch mal mehr als ein Gerät anschließen. Und zwar dann möglichst eben nicht die Hälfte meiner USB-C-Funktionalität verdienen. Gibt es denn so was jetzt schon und kostet so was? Was kostet so was?
Also, ne, es gibt auf jeden Fall von Apple für das MacBook halt schon mal diese Adapter. Die sind im Prinzip USB-C-Switches, weil da kommt ja ein USB-C-Port raus und USB und Strom separat.
Das ist nicht von Apple, das ist von Anker.
Also von Apple gibts da irgendwas?
Da hab ich übrigens die USB-3-Variante, von dem genau demselben Gerät, das kann ich durchaus empfehlen. Dieser Ethernet-Adapter, der ist cool.
Was? Ach so ein Ethernet mit USB-3-Pop.
Genau, das gibt es auch mit einem anderen Stecker, den gibt es auch mit einem USB-2-3-Stecker. Er hat ein blauer Ding, also ist ein USB-3-Stecker. Und der funktioniert gut.
So was ist zum Beispiel schon mal ganz cool hier. Das kannte ich jetzt auch noch nicht. Anker USB-C auf 3-Port USB-Hub mit Ethernet. So, da hast du halt einen... Klaro, da hast du einen Dongle und hast halt... Ja, was?
Das ist dann nicht so nullerart. Guck mal hier, geil, du kaufst dir so ein kleines Schnuffi, so ein Plaste-Bimsel. Ja, okay, aber so steckst du dir ran, ey Mann! Und dann hast du USB und Ethernet, geil!
Ja, aber du kannst ja jetzt sozusagen über einen einzigen Stecker, kannst du stromversorgt oder auch stromversorgend dir im Prinzip genau die Konfiguration an Ports, die du so auf einen Griff haben willst, egal wie Legacy. Ja, das Ding kann man halt wegen auch noch Kopfhörerport und irgendwie Firewire und was weiß ich.
Wählen sie jetzt die Nummer neben ihrer Landeslage.
Wenn sie jetzt anrufen, kriegen sie noch ein zweites USB-Zähndongel dazu.
Local Talk, was auch immer du haben willst.
Seriell, das geht alles. VGA kannst du noch darüber rausführen. Also für jeden Schnupsi gibts halt irgendwie das passende Teil.
Aber der Huckel hat recht, diese Ding ist insbesondere deswegen albern, weil wenn du jetzt sagst, ich möchte jetzt nur noch einen Port an meinem Laptop haben, damit mein Schreibtisch nicht so glattert ist, dann legst du mit diesem Ding dein problemlos 10 cm vom Rechner weg. Weil dann hast du nämlich den ganzen Klatter an dem Ding dran zu hängen und das hängt per 10 cm Kabel an deinem einen Port von deinem Laptop.
Nein, nein, das ist ja keine Desktop-Solution.
Das wäre zum Beispiel was so, was ich für meinen mobilen Recording-Bedarf gebrauchen könnte.
Für deinen mobilen Recording-Bedarf. Auf dem Dampfer.
Um mal auf das MacBook Pro und wie es vielleicht sein wird zurückzukommen.
Nehmt mit dein Pult nicht mit.
Ich verstehe eure Schmerzen, aber ich finde, dass ein Rechner, der wirklich nur noch eine einzige Art von Schnittsteller hat, mit Ausnahme Kopfhörer, finde ich eine geile Vision.
Ja, Vision super.
Solange genug Ports da sind, weil du kannst sie dann auch alle austauschen. Ich habe häufig das Problem, was weiß ich, Thunderbolt, da stecke ich halt jetzt meinen Gigabit-Ethernet dran. Das war's. Das ist, wenn ich da jetzt noch mal eine Platte ran schließe.
Nee, steckst du eben nicht. Geht nicht. Doch, außer wenn die Platte ein zweites Loch hat.
Wenn ich deinen Bildschirm anschließen will. Was denn?
Ja, dann steckst du den Bildschirm dran, steckst die Dinge in dein Thunderbolt-Port von deinem Bildschirm. Beziehungsweise dein Bildschirm hat ein Ethernet drin, wenn es ein Thunderbolt-Bildschirm ist.
Ja, oder vielleicht auch nicht. Und HDMI und du willst nur irgendwo auf irgendeinen komischen Bildschirm raus, aber du brauchst in dem Moment auch Ethernet, dann geht es einfach mit diesem Gerät nicht, es sei denn, ich hol mir dann noch ein Thunderbolt-Splitter. So hätte ich vier Ports, die ich einfach...
Wer braucht das?
Also, wenn du viel anschließen willst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du dann auch deine Ports zu 100% genutzt oder zu einem hohen Maß genutzt bekommst und nicht rumgammeln und nur staub fangen. Recht hoch.
Mir geht es nicht darum, dass ich meine Ports jedes Mal in jeder Gelegenheit maximal ausnutze, sondern egal wo ich bin und mir wird ein Kabel gereicht, ohne darüber nachzudenken, ob ich eine passende Dongle dabei habe.
Das probiere ich übrigens mal aus. Wie steckt der denn nächstes Mal ein Kabel?
Dann brauchst du auch noch VGA. Guck mal, in deinem Firewire-Port, da brüten doch wahrscheinlich schon Schweine.
Ich stecke tatsächlich täglich da ein Firewire 100-Kabel rein.
Was hast du noch für Legacy-Kram?
USB 3, wo USB-Sticks, Mäuse, Tastaturen angeschlossen werden, tagtäglich, mehrfach, iPhone, Ladegeräte.
Magisch werden sich alle USB-Sticks da draußen in USB-C.
Ich hab einfach, ich bin einfach so, mit diesen Dongles hab ich einfach keine gute Erfahrung. Ich bin ein gebranntes Kennhau, es gibt ja noch andere Sachen, die nicht prognostisch sind.
Wir leben ja von der Kontroverse.
Konzentrieren wir uns doch auf das andere Problem, was dieses MacBook mit sich bringt.
Keine Tastature.
Hatten wir nur noch einen USB-C. Tastatur, wenn er einen haben will, steckt sie da dran bei USB-C.
Ja, also diese OLED-Leiste, die gerummelt war, wird vielleicht tatsächlich eine sein und die Frage ist natürlich, What's up with Ask?
Ja, dann wandert es runter, dann machen sie aus dieser komischen Dachtaste mit dem Kringel drüber, die braucht eh keine Sau.
Die machen die nicht.
Die benutzen manche Leute als Mumble Push to Talk Taste oder sowas. Machst du eine halbe Taste und oben drüber eine Escape?
Die können doch nicht aus einer Escape-Taste so ein wuschiges...
Wer braucht denn Escape?
Das sind nur Entwickler und die stinken gegen.
Ich bin jetzt Apple und dann sage ich, wer braucht denn Escape im normalen Apple? Standarddings, wo braucht man denn eine Escape?
Um einen Dialog abzubrechen.
Haben die doch geändert.
Da klicken die alles mit der Mosfet.
Was?
Apfel D ist Desktop. Apfel D ist Desktop. Im Falle.
Escape funktioniert aber immer noch.
Ja, wollen die auch abschaffen, das ist deprecated.
Den modalen Dialogen.
Ist falsch, springt zum Desktop. Hab ich hier Open Dialog gerade aufgemacht. Escape macht den Open Dialog zu.
Aber vom Team sind schon richtig. Also Escape ist eine traditionelle Entwickler-Taste. Das stoppte das ja in den Co-Est-Zeiten. Normale Anwender benutzen auch keinen rumgeschobber auf dem Trackpad mit zwei Fingern. Die klicken halt, wie sie von früher gewohnt sind, mit der Maus auf den Scrollbar und schubbern mit dem durch die Gegend.
Normale Anwender haben, anormale Anwender zu werden, das ist mir scheißegal, was normale Anwender machen.
Wir sprechen ja auch nicht vom MacBook Normal, wir sprechen vom MacBook Pro.
So sieht es nämlich auch. Make MacBook Pro, Pro again.
Ja, aber auch die Pro-User sind nicht die stinkenden Entwickler. Das sag ich jetzt aus Sicht von Apple. Was hat das jetzt mit den Entwicklern zu tun? Entwickler wollen wieder ein Betriebssystem, die wollen solche Apps wie Terminal haben, die wollen solche Sachen wie welche Files ändern und all so ein Scheiß. Und damit ist jetzt eh demnächst Schluss. Also OS X, keine Ahnung, 11 oder so was, sieht dann so aus wie iOS auf dem Telefon und so und dann hat das ein Ende mit dem gestochen. Das haben wir schon ein paar Mal vorher gesagt und die sagen, wir nähern uns da immer.
Nee, finde ich gar nicht, dass wir das tun.
Doch, doch. Neulich schon mal, letztes Jahr habe ich doch gesagt, in dem Moment, wo Apple ihre tolle Developer Suite für Linux oder Windows vorstellt, weißt du, dass das Ende von OS X gekommen ist und zwar das Ende von OS X, wie wir es kennen, die werden immer noch diesen Quatsch da verkaufen, aber dann spielen sie da eine iOS drauf, was man schön zunageln kann, dass die User nicht mehr an die bösen Bösen Files drankommen und dann ist da ein Ende.
Ja, die Diskussion gibt es schon lange, aber bisher ist nichts in dieser Richtung passiert.
Wir werden sehen, wenn sie ihre Developer Suite jetzt vorstellen.
Natürlich werden wir sehen, aber das habe ich vor fünf Jahren schon gehört, wir werden es sehen. Und was haben wir gesehen? Nichts haben wir gesehen.
Was wir sehen ist, dass Escape verschwindet.
Wenn Escape verschwindet, dann wird es langsam schwierig. Ich meine, ich kann ja auch verstehen, dass man so der Meinung ist, dass dieser ganze Metascheiß irgendwie auch echt verwirrend ist. Kontroll, Alt, Option, Function. Das verstehen ja schon die wenigsten.
Aber die arbeiten auch schon an der neuen Tastatur.
Dann heißen die Tasten auch, dann haben sie auch alle drei verschiedene Namen.
Badewanne, Propeller.
Drück mal die Apfel-Taste. Command war früher mal die Apple Key.
Steuerung, Strk. String, so war das. String.
String-Taste.
Dann gibt's ja Alt und dann die PC-Juiser kennen, Altgrrr.
Aber Apple ist da schon am Arbeiten an der neuen Tastatur. Die neue Tastatur heißt nämlich Siri.
Sie haben eine Rollentaste, die keine Sau benutzt.
Du meinst, weil sie gerüchteweise jetzt Siri in Mac OS einwarnt?
Nee, weil Tastatur einfach überholt ist.
Hey Siri, bist du demnächst in Mac OS X drin? Bist du in Dennis drin? Nein, das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Dennis wird doch auf sehen, was jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Ja, das Problem mit Spracherkennung ist, die gibt dir einfach nicht genug Confidence. Also man vertraut halt schon vorher nicht dem Ergebnis und deswegen macht man es halt einfach gar nicht.
Also was schon ganz gut funktioniert, ist so diktieren. Ich benutze das beim Autofahren. Wenn mir jetzt jemand dringend eine Nachricht schreiben muss, nehme ich nicht die Hände vom Lenkrad, sondern ich sage Siri, schick es jetzt mal zurück. Da macht es dann immer drei Fehler drin und dann lasse ich sie hinten dran diktieren. Das war Siri. Und dann freuen sich auch die Empfänger. Das geht so.
Wir machen übrigens so ein geiles Themenhopping gerade.
Wir sind bei Eingabesystemen. Lass uns vielleicht noch mal zurückkommen auf diese Tastatur, weil ich finde das schon bemerkenswert. Was die Funktionstasten und die Vision, ihre dynamische Art, was sie sozusagen repräsentieren, als Bildschirm zu realisieren, da gehe ich ja voll mit.
Ich fasse die Dinger fast nie an. Ich mache die Lautsprecher an und aus, und das Bildschirm ist immer heller und dunkler, und das war es.
Die müssen sich nicht noch wangeln. Weil die voll mit so Nerd-Emojis sind.
Also in Minecraft ist FL Fullscreen. Das will ich nicht missen.
Das wirst du ja dann auch beibehalten. Also die Funktion gibt es ja noch. Nur, dass du dann der Tasse das auch ansiehst, dass es Fullscreen ist.
Aber das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass wenn ich einen IPMI-Java-Kline offen hab und im BIOS-Bootscreen den Bootselector auswählen will, dass mir dann die Taste sagt, F11 ist jetzt der richtige Knopf.
Im schlimmsten Fall steht der F11 drauf.
So, dann ist halt alles so wie jetzt auch. Aber in dem Moment, wo du halt Tastatur-Aware bist und irgendwie dem OS sagst, naja, das ist hier so wie ich es gern hätte. Und dann gibt es auch noch die passende Icon-Set dazu. Ich meine, das wird nicht lange dauern. Und gerade so diese ganzen, ja, so Photoshop-Style-Apps, die werden sich über sowas natürlich extrem freuen.
Ja, aber wenn das jetzt The Big Innovation ist, dann muss ich mich aber echt mal gern zurücklehnen.
Gab es übrigens schon von Lenovo. Vor zwei Jahren haben die das irgendwie schon mal probiert.
Das ist kein Tastendongel, wird gerade im Chat dargeboten.
Das ist sogar mit Steckdose wichtig. Das ist glaube ich eher eine Lampe.
Aber wäre auch eine super Idee, einfach USB-C, Escape-Tast.
Escape-Tast mit USB-C, die du dranstecken kannst von der Seite.
Was man mit USB-C alles Tolles machen kann.
Ja, das ist vorstellbar.
Man kann sich auch so ein Power-Mate da irgendwie rankloppen, so ein Universal-Eingabe-Schnupsi, und dann hat man das halt auch alles. Na ja, also keine Ahnung, ob das für mich attraktiv ist. Mein persönliches Dilemma ist natürlich, sie wollen ja, dass er, auf der tollste Computer, die sie je gebaut haben, KlauAZoo, nicht fortführen. Das finde ich ein bisschen evil.
Bauen auch die anderen in den selben Formfaktor und schmeißen muss den Namen weg, oder wie?
Na also im besten Fall ist halt das neue MacBook Pro im Prinzip wie ein eher Bildschirm. Also Größe wird wahrscheinlich etwas größer ausfallen, wobei wenn ich mir jetzt dieses Foto nochmal vergegenwärtige, was da gerade herumging.
So weit nicht, so eine Flachwanze nicht. Wir wollen mal einen ordentlichen Rechner, den man noch so anfassen kann.
Flachwanze, na ich hab ja nichts dagegen, dass die Dinger kompakt sind.
Aber das fühlt sich gerade nochmal nicht so toll an. Da traut man sich doch gar nicht mehr in den Rucksack zu stecken.
Außerflach ist da doch nichts.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade auf, dass diese Screenshot hier, also dieses Foto von diesem Gerät, mit dieser komischen Tastatur, dieselben Dimensionen hat wie mein R.
Ach.
Die Tastatur wird unter Garantie genauso groß sein, wie jetzt auch. Die werden sie nicht größer machen. Also größer bestimmt nicht. Wenn überhaupt kleiner, aber das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Aber die machen da da guck dir bitte doch nochmal an, das ist doch keine Mac-Tastatur. Nee, das ist fucking fake. Weil zum Beispiel die Cursor-Tasten, die machen noch da unten rechts nicht vier fette Dinge, haben jeweils nur für einen Pfeil. Das ist ja Johnny Alf, ich würde gerade sagen ein Grab um, aber...
Die zweite von rechts müsste eigentlich gesplittet sein in zwei, ja.
Ja, diese Tastatur scheint mir eher so ein Fake oder so.
Das ist ein Fake.
Das ist alles Fake und es gibt gar kein OLED.
Wo seht ihr OLED? Ich sehe da wenn denn nur ein Loch.
Die Leiste da oben, aber da ist halt keine F-Taste, da oben müsste ja da hinten.
Da ist ja nichts, da ist nur ein Loch, wo du dann vielleicht ein OLED-Ding dahin machen kannst, aber das ist nur ein Loch.
Also wir regen uns völlig umsonst auf.
Eben.
Es kommt wieder Ethernet rein.
Ja, außerdem ist jetzt eh, aber in fünf Tagen wissen wir es genau. So, next. Du hast Angst?
Nee, also...
Ich will einfach mal ein ordentliches Gerät haben, weil ich hatte jetzt...
Aber dich kann man ja eh nicht zufrieden stellen.
Eben.
Und wenn die dich zufrieden stellen, geht Apple Pleite, weil sie verkaufen nur genau ein Gerät.
Das würde ich ja so jetzt nicht sagen.
Aber, aber wo wir gerade schon bei richtiges Gerät und so weiter sind, also jetzt wo ich mich zu Hause immer mehr mit Audio-Equipment einwiesel und so Tonverarbeitung und so dachte ich mir auch, eigentlich wäre vielleicht so ein Desktop doch gar nicht so schlecht. Und dann habe ich so aus Spaß mal vorsichtig auf eBay geschaut, was so ein Mac Pro 5.1 von 2012 letzte Serie so kostet. Bin fast hintenüber gekippt, dass die Dinge auch immer noch so für 2K und mehr über den Tresen wandern.
Ja, das ist das richtige Gold.
Das richtige Gold. Und Dennis hat jetzt gerade gesagt, der ultimative Mac Pro wäre ein 4.1, über den man dann noch bis an die Oberkante quasi upgraden kann.
Also der 2009er Mac Pro ist physikalisch genau gleich wie dein 2012er von ihm. Gerade erzählt hast, außer dass bei dem 2012er ein Bluetooth-Modul irgendwie eingesetzt wurde, was man selber aber bei dem von 2009 auch machen kann. Dann änderst du noch die Firmware von dem 2009er, dann ist das exakt die gleiche Kiste wie der 2012er.
Und jetzt die Frage, kriegen wir da auch jetzt USB-C ran?
Also USB-C weiß ich nicht, aber es gibt USB 3.0.
Ziemlicher Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht. Weil dazu müsstest du halt ganz anders mit dem Mainboard auf die CPU connected sein. Da brauchst du halt die entsprechenden Bandbreiten zur CPU.
Na gut, also Leute, ihr hört, eure alten Mac Pros sind bald nichts mehr wert. Falls einer von euch noch so ein Mac Pro 4.1 aufwärts abstoßen möchte, ich wäre auf jeden Fall interessiert, allerdings natürlich nicht unbedingt jetzt für 2000 Euro.
Gefickt eingeschädelt, den Plot mit dem USB-C.
Ich finde das Thema ja ganz golden, weil ich hatte nämlich jetzt auch gerade so eine Schreckminute mit meinem Mac Pro. Ich hatte hier so obskure... Erinnert ihr euch noch an die Sendung, die neulich mal fast kaputt gegangen wäre, wenn ich nie noch mal auf Streamback ab zurückgegriffen hätte? Ich hatte ja die Vermutung, dass die Platte kaputt ist. Das stimmte wohl, weil jetzt ist die auch so richtig kaputt. Und dann habe ich halt neue Platte gekauft, die reingesteckt und dann wurde es nur noch obskure. Dann hat er irgendwie diese neue Platte nicht erkannt. Und dann fing er an, irgendwie auch Platten, so mehr nichts, dir nichts nach 50 Sekunden wieder raus zu ejecten. Und alles war auf einmal total weird. Und ich war schon so voll in Panik. Ich dachte mir so, oh Gott, mein Mainboard geht irgendwie den Bach runter. Aber irgendwie nach viel hin und her und mal am anderen Rechner formatieren und so hat er das wieder gefressen. Aber da war ich dann auch so in so einem Schockmoment.
Da dachte ich so, das Vertrauen ist weg.
Was würdest du jetzt machen, wenn dir diese Kisse jetzt vor deiner Nase verreckt?
Du musst cold stand by.
In dem Moment, wo man sowieso darüber nachdenkt, Geld auszugeben, überlegt man natürlich schon, vielleicht wäre ja... Das Problem nur mit diesem aktuellen Mac Pro, der überhaupt nicht mehr aktuell ist. Das Ding ist ja auch schon fast zwei Jahre alt.
Nee, nee, drei.
Ich glaube auch.
Drei?
Der heißt 2013. Der kam dann erst ziemlich spät raus und so. Also eigentlich fast 14.
Ende.
Aber es ist, der heißt offiziell weg pro 2013.
Also zweieinhalb Jahre. Und das Ding ist ja überhaupt nicht up to date.
Nee. Vor allem nicht für den Preis, den die da aufrufen.
Ja, du kriegst da irgendwie keine 5K-Bildschirme angeschlossen, die du innerhalb bei so einem iMac irgendwie hast.
Ja gut, das ist aber auch ein anderes Problem.
Was?
Na, den 5K-Bildschirm, da gibt es immer noch nicht den richtigen Standard für. Deswegen kann der Mac Pro das gar nicht können. Und im iMac brauchen sie keinen Kabelstandard. Das machen die da intern und proprietär und so weiter. Und das geht halt extern erstmal nicht so einfach.
Ja, was heißt das? Es gibt da keinen richtigen Standard für. Du kannst mir doch nicht erzählen, dass sie jetzt nicht mit irgendeiner Display-Port-Version ich weiß nicht, was ist da gerade angesagt?
Ich weiß nicht, wie es ist, aber da hat doch der Gruber geschrieben, er meint, da soll ein Apple-Display rauskommen hier auf der WWDC als 5K-Display, direkt das aus dem iMac. Und welcher Standard das dann könnte. Aber die ganzen Rechner, die gerade rauskommen, die könnten das eigentlich auch alle nicht. Und dann war ja die Idee irgendwie auch von so einem externen Typen an den Gruber, dass das Display ja die Grafikkarte bei sich selbst drin haben könnte und das halt über das Thunderbolt-Ding ins 3 angeschlossen wird und so weiter. Und das fanden sie dann alle voll geil. Und das wäre auch geil, wenn so ein Gerät kommt. Aber irgendwer hat dann auch geschrieben, ja, nee, wird nicht kommen und könnte vergessen. Und dann sind die da auch zurückgerudert. Aber die Idee an sich ist ziemlich cool, dass das Display sozusagen PCI-mäßig angeschlossen wird über so ein Thunderbolt und die Grafikkarte ist im Display drin. Weil ich brauche unterwegs keine Ultra-Hot-Gaming-Grafikkarte, sondern die kann im Display zu Hause bleiben. Und hätte da auch die entsprechende Stromversorgung. Jetzt sind wir ein bisschen abgekommen vom Thema, weil ihr damit wolltet nur sagen, dass es nicht so einfach ist, so ein 5K-Display einfach mal so anzuschließen.
Also DisplayPort 1.3.
Also du kannst...
Was ist ein 5K-Display? Das ist doch... Wie viele Pixel sind denn das?
4K sind 3... 4K war doch...
3840.
3840 mal 2... Mal was? 2440?
2160, glaube ich. Guck mal gerade, was der iMac 5K eigentlich hat, weil das ist ja sozusagen... Das ist ja das, was man haben will. 5K... Graphics... So, das sind dann... Jetzt nichts falsches sagen. 5120 bei 2880. Und das geht mit DisplayPort 1.3.
Und wer hat das?
Weiß ich nicht, aber DisplayPort 1.3 ist vom 15. September 2014. Wenn man vier Leitungen hat.
Vier Lanes meinst du? Oder was?
Ja, hier heißt es Leitung.
Bist du auf der deutschen Seite?
Ja, Entschuldigung. Ich geh auf die englische. Das ist ja recht. Das ist nicht das, was man in der deutschen Wikipedia nachschlagen sollte. Oh ja, das ist doch total professioneller. Wobei das jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen... Lanes. Das ist diese Lanes, ja.
PCI-Lanes sind das?
Das sind letztendlich PCI-Lanes. Genau. Und wenn du halt davon vier zusammenkriegst, dann kriegst du auch irgendwie so ein 5K angeschlossen. Also für meinen Geschmack ist da eigentlich schon genug drin. Man muss halt nur diese Lanes da irgendwie unterkriegen. Jetzt ist diese Thunderbolt 3, hat ja 40 Gigabit. Also nochmal das Doppelte von Thunderbolt 2 und Thunderbolt 1. Das war ja auch 20 Gigabit, aber halt so als 2x10 ausgelegt. Aus welchen Gründen auch.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja jetzt, was auch gerade erstmal so rauskommt. Also es ist nicht, was dieser Mac Pro gerade kann, dieses Thunderbolt 3. Nee, richtig, klar. Hat der Thunderbolt 2 oder ist das auch so?
Jaja, 2.
Jaja, 2, okay.
Genau, aber das könnte sich ja ändern. Also das wäre sozusagen für mich auch relevant. Zumal ich auch, Alter, ich hab ja dieses Motu, ja das war wirklich ein Moment, das war wirklich, also das war ein, wie sagt man, ein emotionaler, sensorischer Event. Ich hatte, ich hatte mir letztes Jahr schon so in so einem Wahn zum Spielen so ein Motu 8M gekauft. Erinnert euch vielleicht, das ist dieses einerseits mit AVB, Ethernet ausgestattete Audiointerface. Und ich dachte ja so, ah geil, weil ich ja immer so viel mit Ethernet mach, so jetzt AVB, Standard und so voll cool, niedrige Latenz, Rock'n'Roll und so. Ja, funktioniert eigentlich irgendwie, aber so richtig überzeugt war ich dann auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, was die Roundtrip-Latenzen waren, die ich da gemessen habe, aber es war irgendwie noch nicht so der Durchbruch. Und irgendwie war das auch alles irgendwie ein bisschen Bremsi. Und dann neulich, dann lag das Ding jetzt hier irgendwie lange Zeit ungenutzt rum, weil ich dafür eigentlich keine wirkliche Anwendung hatte. Und ich hab auch schon mich mit dem Gedanken getragen, das einfach wieder zu verkaufen. Weil wenn man es nicht benutzt, was solls. Aber dann dachte ich mir so...
Wie viel hat es gekostet?
Pff, gar nicht. 2k. Mittlerweile ist es auch schon irgendwie auf 1x runter. Also es ist auf jeden Fall verlustbehaftet. Aber es war halt so Aufbruch Zukunft. Tim dreht durch. Naja, und dann dachte ich mir so, das Ding hat ja auch ein Thunderbolt-Interface. Das hast du ja gar nicht ausprobiert. Das war so unter dem Internet. Und dann hatte ich ja schon von diesen Focus-Ride-Dingern gelesen, dass sie schon mit ganz amtlichen Latenzen kamen. Ich dachte mir so, okay, pack mal aus, mal gucken. Hier, Firmware, wie sieht es aus? Und dann war da gerade seit zwei Wochen irgendwie eine neue Firmware draußen und eine Bitterversion vom neuen Treiber. Mit der großen Überschrift, jetzt mal total niedrige Latenz. Das schreiben sie ja immer. Also es ist ja immer Near Zero. Mit unterschiedlichen Größenordnungen von Near Zero. Genau, also wie nah das dann letzten Endes ist, ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Ding. Dann hab ich halt hier so ein Setup gemacht, Hetset angeschlossen, ein bisschen reingequatscht und dann halt durch Reaper durch und quasi von Reaper das Signal zu diesem Interface hingeschickt, von dem Interface wieder Empfang über Thunderbolt, nachdem es da durch den Mixer ging und dann halt dasselbe Signal aufgezeichnet. Dann brauch ich ja nur mal kurz schnipsen und dann kann ich ja direkt messen in Reaper, wie groß die Latenz ist. 0,85 Millisekunden Roundtrip Latenz. Ich dachte, ich breche ins Essen. Das ist der Hammer. Also das ist, das ist echt der... Ja vor allem, ich habe noch von keinem einzigen Interface da draußen jemals irgendwo, also ich muss dazu sagen, bei 96 Kilohertz. Das ist mir auch egal. Ich hätte auch 192 Kilohertz gemacht, ich habe auch 192 Kilohertz ausprobiert, hatte ich komischerweise dieselben Latenzen. Was ich nicht so ganz verstanden habe, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Unterschied zwischen 48 und 96 und ich war halt unter einer Millisekunde. Das ist schneller als mein Digital-Mischpult hier, was zugegebenermaßen auch schon ein paar Jahre auf dem Buckel hat, aber da hat sich auf jeden Fall was getan. Also das interne Processing ist mittlerweile so fast und wenn du halt genug Daten lieferst, dass die Buffer auch was zum Schieben haben, kommt man halt da runter. Und das ist natürlich sehr geil, weil das ist sogar nochmal deutlich besser als das, was ich jetzt hier über Gigabit-Ethernet erreichen kann und zwar deutlich besser. Und es ist vor allem genau in diesem Bereich, wo man wirklich das erste Mal ernsthaft drüber nachdenken kann, alles in Software zu machen. Weil wir könnten jetzt sozusagen über Thunderbolt unsere Stimmen hören und es wäre kein Unterschied zu dem, wie es jetzt gerade ist. Weil jetzt haben wir gerade eine Millisekunde und dann wär's halt auch eine Millisekunde, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass man natürlich dann gleich im Waden noch 1000 Filter und Equalizer und Hast nicht gesehen draufschmeißt. Aber die sind ja eigentlich relativ schnell und können ja dann die volle Performance von dem Rechner nutzen und diese DAWs sind ja auch darauf optimiert, diese Chains relativ performant abzuarbeiten.
Die können das ja auch von Universal Audio so ein Interface nehmen, wo sie den Shark DSP gleich im Interface haben für die ganzen Plugins, die sie so mit anbieten.
Dieser Apollo-Dinger.
Okay, aber wir waren jetzt bei dem Mac Pro und bei 5K Displays und davor waren wir bei...
Dass der Mac gar nicht mehr so Pro ist. Oder nicht so okay.
Um das noch kurz zu Ende zu bringen, Thunderbolt wird wichtig und man will das aber dann auch wirklich in der maximalen Ausbaustufe haben. Also ich kauf mir jetzt nicht einen Thunderbolt 2 Mac Pro für so einen sinnlosen Preis. Also, dass er alt ist, würde mich ja nicht stören. Das stört mich ja an meinem auch nicht. Also meiner ist von 2009 und das stört mich nicht.
Das alleine als Statement ist halt schon echt krass.
Der ist sieben Jahre alt.
Aber da kann man so geil dran rumbasteln und denen halt noch so Leben einhauchen.
Der performt vor allem.
Performen tut die Tonne bestimmt auch, aber das war es auch schon. Kann doch nichts ändern.
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, performt sie in einem Bereich, nennenswert, so viel schneller, dass ich davon auch einen Vorteil hätte. Und das sehe ich halt nicht, weil dieser ganze Grafikkarten-Mumpitz ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich wurscht. Weil ich spiele eh keinen 3D-Scheiß. Ich mache auch keinen Cut und keinen Hass nicht gesehen. Das Einzige, wo es ein bisschen was bringen könnte, ist hier so Final Cut Pro Rendering, wo ich gerade seit drei Tagen an irgendwelchen HD-Videos rumcrunche, die viel zu langsam da rausfallen. Gut, aber das ist halt nicht immer so. Aber so dieser ganze Audiokram langweilt sich einfach diese Büchse. Also ich könnte hier noch viel, viel, viel mehr Kram machen. Aber halt Thunderbolt und tendenziell eben jetzt USB-C, denke ich mal, ist schon so die Maßgabe, die man haben will. Also für Audio wird das auf jeden Fall der Knaller. Ja, so viel dazu. Mein Mac Pro funktioniert auf jeden Fall wieder und ich bin beruhigt. Nur meine SSD spuckt da irgendwie immer wieder nach fünf Minuten aus und ich weiß nicht warum. Hast du das schon mal erlebt, dass so der interne, da wo der CD-Laufwerk dran ist, dass das irgendwie buggy ist? Ich hab die jetzt noch nicht getauscht. Ich muss mal rausfinden, ob es nicht doch eine Macke an der SSD ist. Aber die war eigentlich vorher okay. Deswegen wundert mich das gerade so ein bisschen.
Der iMac hat auch Thunderbolt 2. Du sagst gerade Thunderbolt 3. Ist das latest and greatest?
Na das ist das, was wir jetzt mit USB-C sehen werden. Also wenn USB-C Thunderbolt hat, dann hat das Thunderbolt 3. Und das nach der aktuellen Gerüchtelage. Und das hat halt 40 Gigabit. Und damit müsste halt eigentlich eine Menge zu machen sein.
Ich glaube eigentlich ist das Problem wahrscheinlich, die neuen Geräte sind bestimmt irgendwie auch total super, so auf ihre Art und Weise. Aber Clemens 2010er MacBook Pro, mein 2012er MacBook Pro, dein 2009er Mac Pro Ich hab noch nicht mal Retina.
Nee. Das Problem ist, das Zeug hält zu lange. Und ihr seht einfach nicht ein für fancy Dinge, ein Rechner, der voll funktionsfähig ist, wegzuschmeißen. Früher hab ich die Dinger vererbt, die Leute, die die Dinger vererbt haben, haben die auch alle immer noch.
Meine vorherige Rechner ist immer noch voll in Action.
Vielleicht ist das auch blöde Sentimentalität, aber warum soll ich jetzt meine Dinger weghauen, nur weil es ein neuer fancy Ding gibt, für den ich auch noch viel Geld ausgeben muss?
Mein vorheriger Rechner ist 10 Jahre alt.
Tatsächlich ist sogar mein letztes 17 Zoll immer noch im täglichen Einsatz. Weil wir haben so das letzte Mal ein 17 Zoll gebaut.
Und die, wo ich jetzt kein aktuelles Betriebssystem drauf gemacht hab, ich hab ja noch so richtig Aule Kröten oder so was. Da hab ich jetzt irgendwie so für meine Tests, für WLAN-Tests oder so. Da läuft immer noch ein aktuelles Ubuntu drauf. Und die nehm ich dann da auch noch. Von daher, die Dinger gehen nicht weg. Das ist das Problem.
2009.
Ihr habt da eine klare Ansage, wir wollen gerne einen Mac Pro, der einfach Pro ist.
Und viel häufiger kaputt geht.
Und zwar muss der so geil sein, dass ich ihn haben will. Und dieses komische Tonnendesign, ja, meint wegen, schön, dass man ihn auf den Desktop stellen kann, aber ich stell den auch gerne unter den Tisch. Also, wenn sie da noch gleich so ein Thunderbolt-externes Gehäuse mit irgendwie sechs Slots für Platten mitliefern würden, dann gerne für den Preis. Aber jetzt, ich meine, dass es absurde ist, das Ding kostet auch genauso viel wie die Mac Pros vorher. Bloß kommen die halt jetzt nicht mehr mit Festplattengehäuse. Das heißt, das haben sie sich alles gespart. Das Ding ist eigentlich nur noch ein Lüfter und drei Platinen und das war's.
Hatten wir ja auch letztes Mal schon erwähnt hier, irgendwie gab es da diesen Blogpost bei Marco Amendt, oder ich glaube bei Marco Amendt, dass dieses, sie haben ja immer noch diese Serie in 13 Zoll auch immer noch im Store, diese 2012er-Serie. Und das ist eins der best verkauftesten Notebooks in ihrem Store. Ich habe das auch einer Freundin gefragt, ja, ich bräuchte mal einen neuen Laptop, so irgendwie mein alter iBook hier, also nicht Kloschüssel, aber so ein Plast-iBook noch. Ist jetzt nicht mehr so geil, und das ist auch an allen Ecken und Innen auseinandergefallen. Dann habe ich halt so kurz überlegt, naja, du kannst jetzt schon so einen mit festgelötetem Flash und so weiter MacBook Pro kaufen, aber es gibt auch noch das 13 Zoll, du willst eh ein kleines haben, da kannst du dann selbstständig den RAM und Festplatte und so alles noch irgendwie für richtig kleine Münzen upgraden. Dann haben wir hier das kleinste Modell bei Gravis geschoppt, mit irgendwie noch drei Jahre hier Garantie und so weiter, und haben dann nochmal für einen Spottpreis quasi auf 16 Gigramm und eine fette SSD abgegradet und diese Kiste, die ist so... Ja, weiß nicht, also da bleiben keine Wünsche offen, außer natürlich USB-C und so weiter, aber ich vermisse das einfach so, diese einfach mal aufschrauben und selber nochmal was nachstecken und so weiter, ich verstehe, dass das alles nicht mehr modern ist, aber ach boah, denkt dann jemand noch an die alten Leute? Nee, glaub nicht. Vor allen Dingen, was passiert denn jetzt mit so einer Kiste, wo dann der Flash-Onboard kaputt geht, oder geht die einfach nicht kaputt?
Dann hast du einen Garantiefall. Und wenn es nach der Garantie ist, dann hast du halt eine Schaschkarte.
Oder kann man diese Module selber noch tauschen?
Na diese M.2-Module, das ist ja ein Standard, die kannst du tauschen, aber die ganzen neuen haben nicht mal mehr diese Module. Also die ersten, die sind ganz klein, das ist halt festgelötet. Bei den großen weiß ich nicht so genau, ich glaube da sind diese M.2-Module oder wie die heißen, die kann man schon tauschen.
Na ja, eines schönen Tages wird mich dieses Notebook vielleicht auch mal im Stich lassen, aber ich hoffe es dauert noch ein bisschen. Na ja, das war ja das große Drama, da hatte ich den gerade noch bei Gravis abgestaubt, das letzte Gerät im Bestand, um mir dann ein paar Monate später eine Kanete drüber zu kippen. Aber da war noch Garantie drauf und ich hatte diese Düsseligkeitsversicherung und dann haben sie mir das Mainboard getauscht. Ja, deswegen hab ich es jetzt nur kurz gemacht. Ja, ich wollte mich auch noch ganz kurz erstens entschuldigen, dass ich die ganze Zeit so schniefe, weil Heuschnupfen und so die Gräser blühen. Und apropos Gräser, vielen Dank noch an das Hörergeschenk, was mich vor kurzer Zeit, also vor ein paar Sendungen hier erreichte. Das blieb in der Sendung unerwähnt. Ich wollte dem anonymen Spender noch mal herzlichen Dank ausrichten. Das hat mir große Freude bereitet. Gerne wieder. Andeutig. Ja, das wollte ich auf jeden Fall noch loswerden, weil beim letzten Mal hab ich's aus lauter Euphorie.
Lass mich raten, stand kein Name bei?
Ja, nee, der wollte nicht genannt werden. Ein sehr noble Geste. Ja, ich sag ja einfach mal kurz hier noch so ein kleines Fun-Thema in Anführungsstrichen zwischendurch, das kommt ja auch mit den Brillen. Ich hab nämlich letztens mit einem Kollegen einen Lunch gehabt und den kannte ich vorhin noch nicht. Wir haben halt so ein Konzept so Mystery-Lunch, weil wir haben ja 300 Mitarbeiter und damit man sich gegenseitig irgendwann mal begegnet, wird jeden Monat so eine Gruppe von sechs Leuten zusammengewürfelt quasi, random Number Generator mäßig und dann wird von der Firma das Mittagessen bezahlt und dann kann man mal irgendwie auch mit Leuten quatschen, die mit seinem eigenen Department vielleicht nichts zu tun haben, dass man halt nicht so total anonym bleibt.
Eine coole Idee macht nur jeder so, dass das so ein bekanntes Konzept von mir kommen.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ich habe noch nie davon sonst gehört, aber auf jeden Fall waren vier der sechs Leute verhindert und ich war nur mit einem dann da und wir hatten...
Das ist keine Pflichtveranstaltung, nehme ich an.
Nee, die waren auch krank oder Urlaub oder was auch immer. Und auf jeden Fall haben wir dann so über alles mögliche gesprochen, irgendwie stellte sich dann aber raus, dass der gute Mann farbenblind ist und so eine rot-grüne Schwäche sozusagen hat, die wohl relativ ausgeprägt ist. Also wenn er auf eine grüne Wiese guckt, dann ist das halt eher so eine Graumélange und auch so verschiedene Zwischentöne, die er eigentlich zwar schon identifizieren kann, da braucht er halt einfach eine Weile, um zu sagen, ah, das ist also jetzt rot oder blau oder turkis.
Aber so geht das Grün ja nicht in Grau, sondern kann man einfach Rot und Grün nicht unterscheiden.
Ja, nee, das ist... Also er meinte, das ist tatsächlich so eine indifferenzierte Melange, also so... Und dann hat er mir aber erzählt, also dann war ich erstmal so, oh ja, scheiße, bestimmt nicht so geil. Und dann meinte er, ja, aber es gibt jetzt Brillen, die einem sozusagen dieses Symptom oder diese rot-grün-Schwäche halt oder diese Farbblindheit lindern oder, wie soll man sagen, also es halt verbessern, die Farbdifferenzierung. Und er meinte, er hätte sich jetzt eine bestellt und nächste Woche kommt die an und er ist schon ganz aus dem Häuschen und so. Und dann meinte ich, alles klar, sag mal Bescheid, wenn die ankommt, weil würde mich mal interessieren, inwieweit dir das denn jetzt wirklich so hilft. Ich finde das ja immer ganz geil, wenn im 21. Jahrhundert dann doch mal, oder generell Materialforschung und so, Prozesse dann mal dazu hinwirken, dass Menschen auch wirklich mal was geholfen wird und nicht nur irgendwie schneller und besser und so hier. Genau, und dann kam die Anwohle und ich hab, er hat es mir nicht geschrieben, ich hab ihn nur irgendwie im Büro rumlaufen sehen mit so einem breiten Grinsen und einer Sonnenbrille auf. Und ich dachte mir, ob das schon die Brille ist. Und ja, wenn man auf die Seite geht von diesem Hersteller, genau, dann sieht man auch, dass es so halt Sonnenbrillen sind. Und er meinte, also ich hab ihn natürlich gefragt, und, und, und, ist jetzt alles bunt und so weiter. Und er meinte, na ja, also er hätte sich natürlich einen etwas deutlicheren Effekt noch erwünscht. Also sozusagen natürlich volle Herstellung der Kompetenz. Also er meinte, es wäre halt natürlich subtiler, als er sich das in den Träumen ausgemalt hätte. Aber einerseits muss er jetzt wohl nicht mehr überlegen, welche Farbe welche Farbe sein könnte, sondern es ist ihm jetzt sozusagen intuitiv schon klar. So von der Unterscheidung. Und wenn er jetzt einen Baum oder eine Wiese anguckt, dann ist das jetzt auch eine richtige Farbe und nicht so ein indifferenziertes. Wenn du da so ein bisschen runterskreuzst, da ist so technology-mäßig. Also so wie ich das verstanden habe, und ich hab da jetzt auch nur erstmal grob drüber gelesen, ist wohl das bei dieser Rot-Grün-Schwäche das Problem, dass sozusagen die Spektrumswahrnehmung sich da überlagert. Also da, wo sozusagen deine Rotrezeptoren sind, deine grünen Rezeptoren, da gibt es sozusagen so eine Überlagerung. Und da unten siehst du das auch, dass das Spektrum sozusagen quasi so zusammenläuft. Und genau, da sieht man übrigens in dem einen Bild, wie das dann aussieht, quasi für ihn. Das ist halt nicht, das rote Haus ist da nicht rot, sondern ist halt so ein beige, orange, melange, ja.
Sie hätten ja mal ein Bild zeigen müssen, wie es vorher aussah, weil das ja nur das echte und wie er es jetzt sieht, aber man sieht nicht, wie er es sonst gesehen hat. Nee, das ist schon mit Brille, oder?
Hier sind doch beide, rot und grün ist ziemlich das gleiche.
Genau.
So, solving the problem, aber...
Und was sie halt machen ist sozusagen, sie nehmen, also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, nehmen sie einen Bereich aus diesem Überlappungsbereich raus und filtern den weg. Jetzt kommen wir ein Stück hoch.
Ich meine, kommen jetzt gerade diese Farbtests und bei dem zweiten ab gar nichts.
Ja, das kann auch an deinem Beamer liegen. Wir schicken genau da, siehst du, so dieses Spektrum und dann filtern sie quasi genau an der Überlappungsschnittstelle sozusagen diesen Bereich raus.
Die machen die Trennscherfe einfach größer.
Genau.
Das heißt, es gibt dann weniger Überlappung, das heißt, das könnte dann auch das Grün grüner sein oder was?
Genau, sie sagen auch, wenn du als Normalfarbsehender quasi dir die Brille aufsetzt, kriegst du so einen Saturation Boost. Ich hab sie noch nicht aufgesetzt, weil er hat mir dann geschrieben, dass er irgendwie so, ja ja, aber nachdem er geschrieben hat, dass es etwas subtiler ist, als er sich das erhofft hatte, hab ich dann gefragt, und wie siehst du jetzt so Bäume und so weiter? Na ja, sind jetzt halt Farben und ich hab schon den ganzen Tag so eine kleine, cooler Freudenträne im Auge und so, da wollte ich jetzt nicht so hingehen, lass mich auch mal aufsetzen. Und dann dachten wir, ja okay, guck mal hier den ganzen Tag und die nächste Woche erstmal bunte Bilder an. Ich werde die bestimmt mal fragen, dann bei Gelegenheit die auch mal aufzusetzen. Die gibt's, ich weiß nicht, ob das Euro- oder Dollarpreise waren, die ich da gesehen hab, es gibt da tausende verschiedene Designs. Die meisten kosten 350 oder 250. Und gibt's auch wirklich in allen möglichen bekannten Farben und Formen sozusagen. Was steht da? Es gibt irgendwie 350, 450 und ich glaube, es gab auch noch so eine Economy-Modelle. Ich glaube, er hat sich auch erst mal eine günstigere Bestell sozusagen, um überhaupt mal zu gucken, ob es was bringt. Genau, die Webseite heißt oder die Firma heißt enchroma.com, falls euch das mal interessiert. Ich fand's auf jeden Fall cool, weil ich davor halt auch noch nie was davon gehört hab. Wir haben einige Kollegen, die so eine Fahrwahrnehmungsschwäche, Farbblindheit haben, das merkt man dann immer so. Ja, hier, also ich versuch gerade rauszufinden, warum unser Bild kaputt ist und dann sagen so die Engineers, na da wo es rot ist und stehen halt so daneben. Du bist gerade dreimal vorbei gescrollt und dann so, ja für dich ist das rot. Also es ist auch öfter, also vorher war mir das eigentlich total fremd, dass ich irgendjemand, also ich hab noch nie jemand gekannt. Und dann stellte sich jetzt aber so in der Firma doch öfters raus, dass es gar nicht so selten ist, wie man vielleicht denkt. Manche Leute erzählen es vielleicht auch einfach nicht die ganze Zeit, aber es gibt halt in der Firma gab es jetzt echt schon oft Situationen, wo so der eine oder andere in so ein Fettnäpfchen gelatscht ist, weil man halt annimmt, dass einfach alle die Farben gleich sehen. Na klar. Und das krasse, was ich dann auch festgestellt habe, ist, dass ganz viele so Workflow-Tools, weiß nicht, Trello oder wie sie nicht alle heißen, die haben halt auch immer diesen Colorblind-Mode. Weil normalerweise ist halt so, ja, alles grün, alles rot oder so, ne? Die Standard-Farbgebung, aber es gibt halt auch den Modus, okay, wenn du halt irgendwie eine Farbbeahningungsschwäche hast, dann hier gibt's mal noch die anderen Modi. Und das fand ich eigentlich auch ganz cool, dass diese Awareness oder das Bewusstsein dafür schon auch überall eigentlich ganz gut vertreten ist.
Da musst du einfach einen Entwickler im Team haben, den es betrifft.
Ja, naja, auf jeden Fall, das wollte ich mal erwähnt haben, weil ich davon vorher noch nie gehört hab und vielleicht findet das ja auch ein Hörer oder ein Hörerin auch ganz interessant.
Ja, also ich finde überhaupt so Accessibility ist eigentlich noch vollkommen untererforscht und da kann man sich ja auch in anderen Bereichen nicht nur was das Visuelle betrifft, es gibt eigentlich eine ganze Menge Rocken. Was mich immer so ein bisschen selber auch verwirrt ist, ich bin immer der Meinung gewesen, dass ja Podcast eigentlich eine geile Sache sein muss für Blinde, bzw. Blinde und überhaupt generell in irgendeiner Form Sicht Eingeschränkte. Hab auch schon mal so den einen oder anderen Hörer kennengelernt, die auch entsprechend eingeschränkt unterwegs sind und mit Podcast was anfangen können. Aber ich sehe da irgendwie noch so richtig keinen Rush, was mich so ein bisschen verwundert. Also, sollten wir blinde oder stark sehbehinderte Hörer oder Hörerinnen haben, würde mich mal Feedback interessieren, welche Podcast-App da sozusagen geeignet ist und ob meine Wahrnehmung eigentlich richtig ist. Wo sind die blinden Podcasts? Ist vielleicht das Aufnehmen zu schwierig? Ist Schneiden eine Sache, die zu sehr am...
Du meinst für die Produzierenden?
Na ja klar, ich meine Podcasts, also wenn man jetzt sozusagen über Special Interest nachdenkt und nicht nur andere, die das jetzt für blinde machen und so, sondern sozusagen, meine Erwartung war ja sozusagen, aus einer blinden Community heraus, also dass man sozusagen das thematisiert und so weiter und das Medium einfach wählt, weil es sich natürlich gut konsumieren lässt. Aber vielleicht ist halt die Produktion das Problem. Vielleicht sind einfach diese Tools zu schwierig und die Tools selber überhaupt nicht accessible. Ich meine, sowas wie Reaper, Accessibility, da ist ja schon mal das User Interface für vollsehende Herausforderung.
Naja, aber ja klar, so Schnitt und grafische Equalizer etc.
Ja, da kommt schon einiges zusammen und diese ganzen Workflows. Andererseits wäre das ja vielleicht auch mal interessant. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass man das nicht auch auditiv machen kann. Also auch ein Schnitt kann ja durchaus, wenn man einen Marker setzt und so, hilfreich sein. Aber ich hab da einfach zu wenig Kenntnis darüber. Deswegen ist das so eine Geschichte. Talking about recording, fällt mir noch ein, dass es hier aus unserem Umfeld auch noch eine Neuigkeit gibt. Es gibt nämlich ein neues Ultraschall. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon gehört hast.
Ich habe es natürlich im Twitter gelesen, aber ich das selber nicht verwende. Was? und Her-Schalten zwischen Normal, Reaper und Ultraschall. Ich mache halt viel anderes Audio und deswegen, ja. Ich meine, so wie ich hier 300Hz aufnehme und so, ich brauche da nicht so den krassen Ultraschall-Workflow. Ich würde den gerne mal ausprobieren, aber so wie wir uns da jetzt arrangiert haben, ist das eigentlich schmerzfrei genug.
Gut, wenn man halt ohnehin viel mit Reaper macht und da weiß, wie man damit klarkommt, meinetwegen, fände ich trotzdem mal interessant, ob du nicht vielleicht einfach mal das auf so einen neuen User draufschmeißt und da einfach mal installierst und mal guckst, ob du damit irgendwie auch klarkommst.
Also ich komme damit bestimmt klar. Ich finde ja auch das Interface sehr ansprechend natürlich und sowieso, also ich habe da überhaupt keine Bedenken, dass das gut funktionieren würde. Ich habe nur eben die primären Bedenken so Workflow, Crossover und...
Na klar, es ist halt ein anderes Tool danach. Es ist ja eben einfach für Podcasts gemacht und das funktioniert ja insofern auch ganz gut. Wie Clemens schon angedeutet hat, also Ultraschall 2.2 ist jetzt draußen, Ultraschall 2.2 kommt mit so ein paar Bugfixes und Verbesserungen. Windows Support mit Feature Parity auch. Also man kann jetzt sozusagen unter Windows dasselbe tun. Habe ich gelesen, habe ich nicht ausprobiert, interessiert mich nicht. Aber trotzdem schön und ja und was halt neu mit dabei ist, sozusagen als die große Neuerung, ist, dass eben das Studio Link mit ausgeliefert wird. Jetzt ist Studio Link nicht so schwierig zu installieren, aber es hilft ja auch schon mal, wenn man das dann eben auch nicht erst noch mal tun muss und dazu sind dann im User Interface eben so Sachen wie, leg mir eine neue Studio Link Spur an, wo dann ja schon diverse Einstellungen gemacht werden müssen, weil das ist ja so ein Trick. Also man benutzt quasi das Audio Plugin, um eine Verbindung herzustellen, also so wo man sonst sagt, okay Echo Filter, ich habe ein Inputsignal und mehr oder weniger dasselbe kommt raus und aufnehmen will man, aber das Original hat man halt hier dann so das Detail, naja, das Plugin ist quasi nur so ein Durchreichen und das was zurückkommt, ist halt einfach die andere Seite. Da will ich natürlich nicht mich aufnehmen, sondern ich möchte natürlich das was von der anderen Seite kommt aufnehmen und das sind alles so Sachen, die man einstellen muss. Mit Ultraschall muss man das halt nicht, sondern man sagt einfach mach mir eine Studio Link Spur und dann ist sie einfach auch schon richtig konfiguriert und tut das Richtige und da Studio Link ja selber schon so mit N-1 Geschichten kommt, kann man halt aus einem Reaper heraus jetzt bis zu acht Leute aus der Ferne mit reinholen. Bleibt natürlich noch das Problem, wie kommen die rein? Und diese Skype-Einfachheit mit starte noch eine App und fertig, die ist halt noch nicht da, aber da wird dran gearbeitet. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie lange das noch dauern wird. Ich vermute mal im Laufe des Sommers, ohne jetzt hier für andere Leute Ankündigungen machen zu können, aber das ist so ein bisschen meine Einschätzung, dass zum frühen Herbst, zum späten Sommer hin, da dann die nächsten großen Schritte gegangen werden. Das heißt, dann wird es halt auch so eine App geben, wo man einfach startet und dann weiß man auch endlich mal wieder, wie man Leute, die sozusagen mit Studio Link noch keine Berührung hatten, mal eben schnell rein kriegt, weil die sich natürlich nicht Reaper installieren wollen, irgendwie nur um Gegenpol zu sein.
Aber jetzt habe ich noch mal eine Frage, weil mit dem Studio Link habe ich mich noch nicht so richtig beschäftigt. Brauchen dann alle Seiten ein Studio Link? Also es heißt jeder muss dann ja...
Also wenn du die maximale Qualität über das Internet haben willst, ja. Mit zwei möglichen... also mit der Perspektive, dass sich das noch mal dahingehend ändert. Erstens, was derzeit einfach noch nicht getestet ist, aber was naheliegt ist, dass man Kompatibilität erreicht mit diesem ganzen Broadcast-Kodex, die so in Studios sind. Also wenn man jetzt, das ist natürlich jetzt keine Massenanwendung, aber wenn man jetzt eine Verbindung zum Deutschlandfunk haben will oder so etwas und da quasi so als als Gast teilnehmen möchte, der Philipp-Banzer-Modus zum Beispiel könnte man das nennen. Oder jemand aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen halt einfach so ein Gerät hat, so ein Codec hat. Die neueren Modelle können halt auch Opus mittlerweile. Das sind jetzt noch nicht so viele, aber das ist etwas, was langsam aber sicher seinen Weg in diese Geräte, Generationen findet, weil Opus kostet halt nichts, ist gut, ist prima und schickt sich halt an, zu so einem neuen Standard zu werden. Ich denke, Opus wird langfristig in diesem Bereich alles andere ablösen. Trotzdem hast du natürlich immer noch viel alter Musiktaxi-Kram, MP2, teilweise auch MP3 und auch natürlich hier AAC, ist durchaus verbreitet. Aber Opus kriegen die halt und es ist halt derzeit noch nicht getestet, aber theoretisch müsste es möglich sein, da Kompatibilität herzustellen in der Zukunft. Das zweite Ding ist, noch das ist noch nicht ganz fertig, du kannst natürlich, es handelt sich ja hier um ein Zip-Plugin. Also im Wesentlichen kriegst du Zip-Telefonie direkt in deine digitale Audio-Workstation rein. Und du kannst das halt jetzt mit dem Studio Link Zip-Server verbinden, das ist sozusagen by default einfach da und da brauchst du keinen Vertrag und nix, sondern du installierst das, du startest das und dann hat dein Gerät, dein Rechner in dem Moment eine Adresse, eine Absenderadresse. Darüber kannst du angerufen werden, darüber kannst du anrufen. Andere Studio Link-Teilnehmer. Du kannst aber auch im User-Interface dann reingehen und sagen, ich hab doch aber hier schon ein Zip-Account bei Zipgate oder was auch immer, verbinde mich doch damit und nicht mit Studio Link.
Das ist eine Dorvey-Idee, weil zum Beispiel Zipgate macht keine transparenten Coding-Geschichte. Wenn du bei Zipgate durchtelefonierst, zwingen die dein Codec auf G700FA.
Ja, klar.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel die Telekom, die macht es transparent. Du kannst den Telekom-Sib-Sauer nehmen, wenn du Telekom-Anlöschungsrechts und Links hast, kannst du den nehmen und da kannst du einen transparenten Codec auswählen. Also deine Endgeräte können den Codec selber aushandeln. Wenn du durch Subgate durchtelefonierst, können deine Endgeräte vorschlagen, was sie wollen. Wenn da kein G700FA dabei ist, lehnen Subgated ab. Und wenn es dabei ist, referiert es den und fertig, peng.
Und machen die auch G722 vielleicht? Aber die Telekom?
Ich hab da schon ein paar Mal, da gibt es ja auch Zuhörer von uns, die da arbeiten, hab die schon ein paar Mal angemaut, hab gesagt so, hallo, jetzt 2015 und jetzt 2016, aber die haben immer tolle andere Projekte. Und hab denen gesagt, hallo, eure große böse Konkurrenz mit dem Rosa T ist jetzt schon etliche Monate und Jahre am Start mit HD-Codec und so. Wie wird denn jetzt mal bei euch? Und dann wird dann leider mal nur rumgedruckst. Da hat halt das Marketing andere Prioritäten bei denen.
Also du meinst, man kann jetzt...
Du kannst nicht zipgate, kannst du nur eine normale, stumpfe 3,1 Kilohertz Telefonie machen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier meinen Telekom VDSL IP-Einschluss mit der Fritzbox, da könnte ich meinen Studio Link auch so programmieren, dass er sich an dem Zip-Server, meinem Telekom Zip-Server anmeldet. Und da kann ich dann mich mit einem beliebigen Endpoint verbinden und kann mit dem aushandeln, was ich mit dem sprechen will. Und wenn der G722 kann, und ich kann das auch, dann geht das.
Und wenn der Opus kann, du auch, geht das auch.
Okay. Und G722 ist ja das, was diese HD-Telefonie im...
Im Festnetz oder im Mobilfunk...
Im iPhone zum Beispiel, am iPhone 6 ist das, glaube ich.
Genau, nutze ich im Insta und seitdem ich da VoiceOver LTE sowieso schon früher, aber jetzt mit VoiceOver LTE noch viel mehr und mehr Leute und so, weil ich jetzt auch mehr Leute angeknipst haben auf ihren Endpoints und so.
Perspektivisch soll halt dieser G722-Kodek auch noch in Studio Link aufgenommen werden, sodass er halt Opus und G722 kann und dann...
Dann kann man ihn auch mit dem iPhone anrufen.
Und dann kann man ihn halt auch mit dem iPhone anrufen und dann wird es halt echt interessant, weil du dann nicht eben diese Top-Qualität hast wie bei Opus, aber eben...
Aber du hast einen Interview-Partner, die nicht mehr aus der Blechdose klingen.
Genau, so und dann ist das sozusagen auch dein Broadcast-Telefoniekodek direkt in der Software, direkt in der Spur und du kannst halt mit bis zu acht Leuten Telefonkonferenz machen und die Leute brauchen eben nichts anderes als ein iPhone und ein Headset und fertig.
Acht Leute Konferenz heißt, der liefert dir dann acht einzelne Spuren ab? Okay, dieser der Beagle-Bone da oder was?
Nee, das ist ja in dem Moment einfach Software auf deinem Rechner. Der Beagle-Bone ist sozusagen dasselbe auf einer dedizierten Hardware.
Und der kann das auch. Der stellt sich dann da für dich wie ein USB-Device oder was? Ich weiß nicht, ob da die Limitierung auch bis acht geht.
Ich weiß nicht, wo da die Limits sind von der Hardware, wie viel der gleichzeitig prozessen kann. Ich glaube, der wird nicht acht schaffen. Wieso?
Dann musst du dir nur von links nach rechts schaufeln, wenn er nicht umkodieren muss. Egal.
Gut. Ich weiß es einfach nicht. Ich gehe nur irgendwie gerade...
Der USB-Sound emulieren und blalalala und so.
Keine Ahnung, wo da jetzt die Begrenzung, ob es welche gibt. Ich vermute mal, es gibt welche, aber ich weiß es auch nicht so genau.
Aber jedenfalls, du kannst diese Zuf Studio Link in deinem Reaper oder so was, beziehungsweise in deinem Ultraschall, hast du jetzt sozusagen 8 Einwahlleitungen oder Auswahlleitungen oder wie ich immer.
Genau. Also über dieselbe Nummer kann ich halt 8 verschiedene Verbindungen machen.
Oder über verschiedene Nummern oder wie ich immer.
Oder auch über verschiedene Nummern wie auch immer möglich.
Weil viele Provider erlauben dir, also die Billigprovider erlauben dir gar nicht mehr als zwei Calls mit nochem Anklopfen oder 4 Calls oder so was über eins und zwei Calls zu machen.
Also das ist an der Stelle halt unlimitiert. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel man über die Telekom machen könnte über den SIP 2.0?
Ganz eingehend kannst du glaube ich ein paar machen. Also ich hab das schonmal hingekriegt, über einen Telekom-Account glaube ich mal vier Gespräche zu machen, allerdings nicht alle in einer Richtung. Kannst zum Beispiel nur zwei abgehende machen. Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, warum sie das machen. Weil sie vermarktet ja so, wie schmeißt dein ISDN weg, nimm hier VoIP, hast du das selber erstmal und noch ein paar Features mehr, wie eben HD, Telefonie, bla bla bla. Auf der anderen Seite werden die Dinger ja nur vermarktet mit Flat Rates. Du kriegst ja gar keinen VoIP von der Telekom, was irgendwie minutentarifiert ist, jedenfalls nicht als Privatkunde oder so. Und wenn du da eine Flat Rate drauf hast, dann willst du da nicht beliebig viele abgehende Kanäle drauf haben. Da hätte die Telekom dann doch ein anderes Problem, wenn dein ganzes Stadtviertel da drauf telefoniert. Und deswegen haben die da die Limitierung drauf. Das haben die meisten. Also du musst ja gucken, auch so eine Buden wie Zipgate, wo du ja auch so Trunk kriegst oder so Dinger. Das wird dann immer geguckt, weil gerade wenn du Flat Rates drauf hast, dann limitieren sie sozusagen deine Anzahl deiner abgehenden Gespräche. Du kannst zwar dann höher buchen, da musst du aber eben auch mehr bezahlen, weil du kannst dann auch n-mal Flat Rate benutzen. Ich glaube, solange die mietert sind, also solange du für die Minute irgendwas bezahlst, gibt es auch Zip-Provider, die sagen, mach doch so viele Calls, wie du willst, das kostet dein Geld und dann mach doch. Da gibt es also unterschiedliche Strategien. Man kriegt das schon hin. Also nimmst du eine zweite Nummer und machst dann noch mal vier Calls drauf oder du buchst dir was, was ein bisschen Geld kostet.
Ich hoffe ja, dass Studio Link irgendwann auch nochmal Telefonie-Backend dazu bekommt, aber ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen...
Dann hast du wieder das Problem, das musst du wieder betreiben, das Ding. Ja, aber gerade wenn du dann einen Anschluss hast ins normale Telefonienetz, nicht nur als Studio Link zu Studio Link benutzt, das kannst du ja irgendwo hinschmeißen. Aber wenn du das Link hast ins normale Telefonienetz, dann kommt wieder so eine Bundesnetzagentur und möchte von dir Dinge, viele Dinge und viel Papier. Ab dem Moment, wo du öffentliche Telefoniedienste anbringst.
An dem Moment, wo man Rufnummern hat.
Ja klar, wenn du Rufnummern hast, die du sozusagen weitervermietest oder damit machst, also einen öffentlich zugänglichen Telefoniedienst anbietest, haben die da so eine Handvoll Auflagen.
Ja, aber gibt es denn nicht irgendwelche richtigen SIP-Provider, die nicht meinen Codec irgendwie einschränken und die ordentliche Kapazitäten am Start haben für bezahlbares Geld?
Telekom.
Ja, aber nicht der normale Anschluss, sondern...
Der SIP-Gate macht das auch nicht, was auf der SIP-Gate macht das, nicht weil er böse ist oder weil er zu blöde ist, sondern weil sie halt relativ lange am Markt sind und dort in ihrer Vergangenheit gefangen sind.
Aber gibt es heute einen SIP-Provider, wo ich jetzt...
Der nicht in die Telekom ist, der transparente Codex kann.
Ja, wo ich sagen kann, ich hätte gerne was, wo ich acht Gespräche gleichzeitig machen kann und wo ich meinen Codec aushalte und wo V6 läuft. Gibt es nicht?
Nicht, dass mir das bekannt wäre. V6, SIP-Gate hat vor ein paar Monaten angeknipst, weil sie wollen ja gerne die ganzen Kabelkunden wieder haben, die ja weggelaufen sind, seitdem Kabelkunden nur noch V6 gekriegt haben in manchen Bundesländern und so. Das haben sie inzwischen gemacht. Aber die Codec-Nummer ist so ein Thema, das stammt aus der Frühzeit von SIP. Was du dafür normalerweise brauchst, gerade wenn du Telefonie-Gateways oder so was betreibst, musst du Endgeräte haben, die in der Lage sind, auf einem laufenden Gespräch den Codec neu auszuhandeln. Weil du weißt zu Beginn des Gesprächs nicht, mit was du dich da verbindest. Das musst du erst mal sehen. Erst mal, wenn der drüben connectet, kannst du ja mit dem aushandeln und feststellen, ach, du kannst ja auch so diesen und jenen Codec und so. Das heißt, du brauchst erst mal so einen gemeinsamen Nenner, auf dem du zum Beispiel die ganzen Ruftöne oder Ansagen oder so was machen kannst. Der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner dafür ist aus der Anfang der SIP-Zeit das G711U und G711A. Das sind die normalen Telefoniekodex. So und wenn man jetzt hingeht und sagt, ich möchte das aber gerne sexy machen, dass denn, wenn die Verbindung hergestellt wird, muss ich on the fly noch mal einen anderen Codec aushandeln. Das konnten aber die ersten SIP-Geräte nicht. Der Standard hatte das immer drin, aber die Dinger waren halt aus China billig, scheiße, implementiert, da wird es einen neuen Codec aushandeln und dann ist das Ding erst mal explodiert und all so Zeugs. Und deswegen sind viele von den kommerziellen Provider in den Hinblick gesagt, ja, pass auf, wir machen einfach keine Codec Greening Negotiation. Wir nageln es nahe fest auf G711A und fertig. Und rekorden alle unsere eigenen Ansagen und Ruftöne und Tralala und was wir so haben, alles in G711A und gut ist. Dass es jetzt inzwischen die Leute langsam hier backen gekriegt haben, Zip-Clients, Hardware-Clients, aber auch Soft-Clients zu bauen, die diese Codec Greening Negotiation hinkriegen, ist halt so ein bisschen an denen jetzt vorbei gegangen. Dafür sind die halt einfach zu lange am Markt. Und das fehlt halt eben. Und die Telekom hat ja eine neuere Implementation, das haben sie ja gerade erst aufgebaut, ist ja noch in der Tropft, ist ja relativ frisch, weil du merkst ja daran, dass die in alle paar Monate noch mal zusammenbricht, wobei das jetzt lange nicht der Fall war. Aber, und die sind auch hingegangen und haben auch brav die Standards durchimplementiert. Da muss man aber wieder sagen, da sitzt garantiert irgendwo in Telekom, in Bonn oder sonst wo, in irgendeinem Forschungszentrum sitzt irgendein kleiner, altgedienter Postbeamter, der einfach die Standards gelesen hat und darauf bestanden hat, dass seine Wender sie einhalten. Die haben einfach mal eine richtig schöne, saubere SIP-Implementation. Von dem, was ich sehe. Da mag es auch andere geben, aber das, was ich bisher so getraced habe, das ist halt einfach, da ist ein sturer Postlehengänger gesagt, das machen wir richtig, sonst nehme ich dir das nicht ab. Und deswegen können die das.
Was noch eine weitere Option ist, Huckel, die mir gerade eingefallen ist, theoretisch, sind natürlich SIP-Telefone, also so SIP-Telefon-Hardware, kann man ja kaufen. Die gibt es jetzt auch teilweise schon angeblich mit Opus.
Ja, Innovaphone hat Opus.
Ja, Innovaphone hat Opus drin. Und wir haben unsere Hände schon an so einen Innovaphone bekommen. Und das geht halt irgendwie alles hinten und vorne nicht. Vor allem, die beschränken halt erst mal ihre Bandbreite. Also du kannst halt nicht so sagen, na hier, schön, super, lass mal 64 Kilobit Opus machen, sondern das ist dann irgendwie reduziert auf 8 Kilobit, weil das haben wir schon immer so gemacht.
Die wollen nicht mehr... Ja, also was soll das?
Ja, das Argument war so was wie, man will ja dann auch genug Bandbreite haben.
Genau. Wunderphone hat ewig lange auch im Laden G729A propagiert. Wer den mal gehört hat, der denkt sich auch so, what the fuck, wir hatten schon ISDN und tralala und jetzt kommt der mir noch mal mit G729A, der klingt wirklich wie aus der Dose. Das haben die im Laden propagiert, weil sie dachten, das ist doch toll, das spart Bandbreite, sind halt Schwaben. Aber sie haben den Opus drin, da kann man noch mal ein bisschen nachkitzeln, da kann man mal nachfahren, die machen ja relativ häufig auch beupdatet.
Streme, strime Bandbreite Spare. Ja, aber es ist, also liebe SIP Telefonhersteller, es hören ja auch einige Mitarbeiter zu, vielleicht auch in Berlin, vielleicht auch in Baden-Württemberg, ich weiß nicht, bei Snom gibt es auch ein Opus-fähiges Gerät, ist das vielleicht zufällig?
Du musst mal eine neue Software drauf machen.
Das, was hier noch rumsteht, ja, das müssen wir vielleicht noch mal gucken. Also das ist so ein bisschen absurd, aber ich weiß, dass...
Das heißt, die Sätze nur eine Bandbreite zu sparen und nicht um Sprachqualität zu erhöhen, ja?
Keine Ahnung, damit es irgendwie auf dem Datenblatt steht. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob wir so... Ja, das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Ich meine, die würden sich da einen riesen Markt aufmachen. Rufen sie den Codec beim Deutschlandfunk direkt an. Das glaubst du, wie viele Radiojournalisten sich so einen Teil dahin stellen würden.
Haben die ja eh schon. Die, die für örtlich-rechtlich arbeiten, die haben ja so ein Ding oder kriegen das gestellt oder so, scheißegal, ob sie da so ein Hardware-Kit...
Ach, die kriegen gar nichts gestellt, scheiß drauf, die kriegen nichts gestellt. Die kriegen Bob nichts gestellt.
Warte mal, den Bunsen, wo ihr seins hernt.
Der Bunsen ist ein fitter Typ, der Plan hat. Das ist jetzt nicht so der Standard.
Ja, wollte ich auch sagen.
Ist nicht so der Standard, dass Menschen Plan haben. Das stimmt ja.
Ja, das ist auch verständlich, aber die Tatsache ist, es ist nicht so, dass du Hardware als freier Journalist irgendwie Hardware gestellt bekommst. Die kaufen die nicht in 3000 Euro, 19 Zoll, Codec, weil das ist das Einzige, was sie kennen. Also ich glaube, diese Idee, dass man das jetzt mit 7 Telefonen machen kann, ist noch gar nicht gekommen. Aber es ist ja auch den 7 Telefonen-Anbietern noch nicht gekommen. Von daher kein Wunder.
Gut, aber jetzt nochmal kurze Zwischenfrage. Das Konzept ist aber auf jeden Fall, man würde dann nicht nochmal, also man nimmt dann auch diese Studio Link-Spur so, wie sie dann da ist, weil die Qualität eh so super ist, dass man das dann auch direkt so veröffentlicht.
Außer wenn dein Gegenüber zwar ein Studio Link, aber ein stinkendes Mikrofon hat.
Na gut, ne, ne, die Frage ist ja, weil jetzt zum Beispiel bei, wenn ich hier den kleinen Gitarrenpodcast aufnehme, dann mach ich das ja über Skype. Und dann schickt mir der Felix seine Spur. Und dann laufen die Uhren in unseren identischen Interfaces halt so ein paar Ticks auseinander.
Details.
Details muss ich immer noch ein bisschen puzzeln, aber...
Wie machst du das? Schneidest du das raus oder staubst du das ganze Ding?
Ja, in Gesprächspausen mach ich einen Cut und schieb's dann wieder.
Ist das auch ein bisschen Sisypheusarbeit, ne?
Was? Bei zwei Stunden läuft's... Also ich glaub der Hörer wird es nicht merken oder die Hörerin.
Die eine.
Die eine. Aber wenn ich die Skype-Spur und die von ihm geschickte Spur sozusagen vorne übereinander lege, mach ich dann noch so ein kleines Klick-Sync, damit ich dann sozusagen die Anfangs-Sync-Marke hab. Und wenn ich dann am Ende, zum Ende springe, zur Verabschiedung sozusagen, dann ist schon deutliches Echo, also so richtig...
große Höhle.
Ich hab das mit Bicycle-Marke ja auch lange Zeit so gemacht und hatte... Ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass ich nie wirklich Probleme damit hatte. Mich hat das selber gewundert. Ich hatte das früher mal... Wir hatten auch irgendwann ja mal so eine Mobile-Max-Sendung aufgenommen, wo wir... Weißt du noch, Dennis, als ich in Toronto war und wir irgendwie zu... alle drei irgendwie an Skype-Endpunkt waren, also jeder war bei sich zu Hause, die Sendung war danach überhaupt nicht mehr zusammenzubringen. Also dieser Triple-Ender, ich hab das irgendwie alles gar nicht mehr richtig zusammengeschnitten bekommen.
Aber sagen wir mal, in unserem Setup ist das... es sind ja nur zwei Spuren. Ich hab die Skype-Spuren, ich leg seine dann da drunter und eben auf diese... und es ist einfach so. Bei zwei Spuren ist es aber okay, weil dann mach ich drei Cuts über die zwei Stunden und schieb's dann wieder so hin, dass halt...
Ja, bei Studio Link kommt das einfach so glasklar über die Leitung, wenn du keine Dropouts hast, also wenn jetzt, wo es halt auch mit Studio Link jetzt in meiner Beobachtung noch problematisch ist, ist natürlich WLAN, schlechte Leitung, kaputte Wattbreite.
Du machst das nicht über WLAN, du machst das nicht.
Du machst das schön über den USB-C zu USB 2 Adapter, oder was hat das Gerät?
Das Studio Link hat doch USB 2, hab ich gesehen. Die Box meiste jetzt.
Ich bin ja jetzt die ganze Zeit nur über die Software-Lösung. Das kann man dann auch alles mit der Box auch machen.
Ach so, die Box braucht man gar nicht für Studio Link?
Nein.
Ah, jetzt wirds interessant.
Jetzt komplett in Software.
Ach so. Im Reaper drin.
Plug in ein AU-Plugin.
Ich dachte aber, diese Box gehört immer dazu. Ah, große Revelation, gut, dass wir drüber gesprochen haben.
Okay, Old News, ich wollte nur kurz sagen, Studio Link ist gestartet als Projekt mit einer externen Hardware. Seit einem halben Jahr gibt es das als AU, erst als VST, jetzt als AU-Plugin auf dem Mac.
64-Bit und so und alles.
64-Bit und so und alles. Du installierst eine Datei in Tille Library, Audio, Components, hast du nicht gesehen?
Und fertig.
Und das funktioniert nicht nur in Reaper, das funktioniert im Prinzip in jeder DAW, die in der Lage ist, Plugins live einzubinden. Wo es zum Beispiel nicht funktioniert, wie sich jetzt gerade herausgestellt hat, ist so was wie Hindenburg, was jetzt diese Radiojournalisten-Sofer ist. Die kann zwar mit Plugins arbeiten, aber erstens ist das Ding im Jahre 2016 eine 32-Bit-Applikation. Und zweitens machen sie halt nicht live, sondern nur beim Rendern. Also du legst halt den Kompressor drauf, wenn du dann rausrendern lässt, dann wird der halt auch benutzt. Aber während des Recordings nicht. Und weil das ja bei Studio Link sozusagen der Trick ist, dass du ein Plugin benutzt, das eigentlich nicht den Input nur an die andere Seite schickt, aber der ja nicht wirklich relevant ist für den Output. Der Output ist nur das, was von der anderen Seite kommt. Aber mit Reaper, wie gesagt, ist das kein Problem. Und es ist im Prinzip auch mit Reaper in Mind gemacht. Also wir schauen jetzt gerade mal, wie sich das so in anderen Systemen so schlägt. Aber mit der Flexibilität von Reaper ist das halt alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Das heißt, du brauchst nichts kaufen.
Okay, alles klar.
Du lädst dir nur Ultraschall runter und du kannst sofort, du kannst deinen Gitarrenpodcast, 300 Hertz, du kannst ihn jetzt auf beiden Seiten mit Studio Link fahren und ihr werdet euch hören, als wärtet ihr im Studio. Keine Kompressionswurst von Skype mehr, kein Zeitklok läuft auseinander, scheiß Dreck, sondern einfach nur...
Und man kann das natürlich auch so im normalen Reaper.
Du kannst das auch im normalen Reaper. Du musst halt nur einen Track anlegen, Plug-In da reinwerfen, Live Monitoring an, wahrscheinlich und so. Du musst den Track so konfigurieren, dass der Output des Plug-Ins recordet wird und nicht der Input der Spur. Der Input der Spur ist, was du sagst, aber da gibt's Tutorial, lalalala, Ultraschall.
Alles klar, dann nächste 300-Hertz-Folge wird dann wohl mal mit Studio Link. Okay, cool, ja, super, weil ja, ich hab immer die ganze Zeit so gerätselt, ja, diese Box und...
Die Box ist halt geil. Also ich hab mir jetzt hier schon so eine kleine Plaste-Versandbox klar gemacht und scharre mit den Hufen, weil da steht jetzt sozusagen demnächst mal ein Software-Update an, aber das ist jetzt wegen der ganzen anderen Aktivitäten, wo Ultraschall zurückgestellt wurde, geworden. So eine Versandbox, da drin ist eine Studio Link Box, ein Ethernet-Kabel, ein langes, ein Netzteil für die Studio Link Box, optional noch ein USB-Kabel, braucht man aber eigentlich nicht, sondern wichtig ist ein USB-Headset. So ein kleines Headset, so ein Biodynamic-Dingsbums, steckst du rein in die Box, steckst du rein in Ethernet, steckst du Ethernet rein in deinen Switch, in deine Fritz-Box, was auch immer, schön langes Kabel, sodass es irgendwie auch irgendwie immer geht. So und dann kann ich das einfach, das Paket jemandem schicken und sagen, du steckst das in deine Fritz-Box und dann setzt du den Kopfhörer auf und dann drückst du vorne die Taste und dann verbindet der sich mit meinem ZIP-Account. Du musst sozusagen nichts machen. Anschließen und wenn das Ding irgendwie blinkt, einmal auf die Taste drücken und dann taucht der einfach so.
Plug in, get connected. There is no step 3.
Alles klar.
Also ich finde, das ist eine super Vision und vor allem mit den ganzen anderen Optionen, wie ich schon angedeutet, demnächst kommt ja Streaming auch nochmal dazu bei Studio Link. Das heißt, du wirst dann auch über das Plugin auch deinen Stream machen können, der dann halt auch über SIP empfangenbar ist mit der entsprechenden niedrigen Latenz, mit der entsprechenden hohen Qualität, aber dann natürlich auch mit Fallbacks für die ganzen Non-SIP, HTTP Geschichten, was natürlich auch sinnvoll ist. Aber da ist noch ein kleiner Weg zu gehen. Aber hier entsteht ein wunderbarer Ort der Audio-Beströmung in jede Richtung.
Cool, ja, dann vielen Dank nochmal für diese Klarstellung. Bitte schön. Das würde meinen Workflow auch durchaus vereinfachen.
Dein Workflow-i?
Ja, ist es denn dann auch mal möglich, vielleicht auch mal in der Freak Show teilzunehmen, per Demo-T?
Das ist ja eher eine konzeptionelle Frage.
Wir wollen ja den Anwesenheits-Counter nicht...
Dann sitzt hier keiner mehr und Tim kommt allein und dann auch nicht mehr. Kennst du diesen Film, wo am Anfang des Films die Studenten so da sitzen, damit das Film dann immer mehr Recorder so auf der Tribüne, wo die Studenten so sitzen und die Schlussszene des Films ist, wie der Vortragende vorne auch nur noch den Player hinstellt und auch keiner mehr da ist. Nur noch Geräte dann in diesem Vortragsraum und sonst ist keiner mehr da. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr welcher Film das war, aber...
Von diesem The Onion, kennt ihr bestimmt, ne? Die Onion News. Die haben mal so ein schönes Ding gemacht zum Thema Outsourcing und da haben sie auch so eine Szene, wo du dann in so einem Konferenzraum sitzt, siehst Konferenztischen, da liegen nur noch Konferenztelefone auf dem Tisch, die sich gegenseitig anquaken. So weit ist das, ne? Das wäre doch auch mal eine Vision. Der Tim will immer ohne Kabel an seinem Rechner und lalala und so, dann kann man auch mal sagen, jetzt mal ohne Humans hier in der Meter-Infektion.
Ja, dann sind alle zu faul und dann sagen alle noch, ja, ich mach diesmal von zu Hause und dann sitzt hier wirklich keiner mehr, ich weiß nicht, ob das so cool ist. Dann lieber mal ne Runde aussetzen, ein bisschen entspannen und dann beim nächsten Mal wieder voll frisch dabei sein.
Ist mir auch recht.
Wenn es natürlich wichtige Dinge zu berichten gibt, wie du das ja auch schon mal überfallweise auf dem Kongress gemacht hast, als wir da auf der Bühne saßen, dann hast du ja auch angerufen, damit ist Fackel Skype. Dafür wäre dann sozusagen diese Studio Linkbox-Konfiguration einfach genau das Richtige, weil du steckst da einfach nur Internet rein, setzt ein USB-Headset auf, Knopf drücken und du bist drin. Da wollen wir hin. Das ist die große Vision.
Das ist das Schlaraffenland des Podcastings. Der Fliegen-Supporter.
Genau.
Deswegen hätte ich gerne ein Studio Link-Klient auf meinem iPhone. Oder ich kann noch einfach, wenn das alles super kompatibel ist, ich hab ja ein Opus-Zip-Klient, der auch richtig wideband und so was macht auf meinem Telefon. Wenn das alles kompatibel ist, kann ich dich ja von meinem Telefon per Opus-Zip-Klient anrufen. Ich benutze schon seit vielen Jahren ein Produkt einer tschechischen Firma, das heißt GroundWire. Das ist die Pro-Version, wo du so alles einstellen kannst und jeden Codec und la la la und beliebig viele Accounts und Pipapo. Und da gibt es auch noch eine billigere Variante von dieser App, weil diese GroundWire kostet 15 Euro oder so, oder 20 und gibt noch mal eine billigere für 5 Euro oder so in dem Dreh von demselben Laden.
Da kann ich nicht alles einstellen oder wie?
Ich frage mich, was die Limitation ist, kann ich dir nicht aus dem Kopf sagen.
GroundWire und habt ihr auch so ein furchtbares User-Interface wie alle anderen?
Du wirst auf jeden Fall was dran finden, was dich stört, das ist mir absolut klar.
Zehn Euro werden hier Business, GroundWire, Zip.
Das ist zum Beispiel das, was ich benutze, wenn ich im nicht europäischen Ausland bin. Das habe ich sehr intensiv benutzt, in Buenos Aires zum Beispiel. Weil so für drei Euro Roaming in 2016 habe ich gar keinen Bock, doch schon gar nicht, wenn ich selber dann Internet baue, was geil ist. Das sieht aber jetzt mal nicht komplett scheiße aus.
Und der kann Opus?
Der kann Opus, Whiteband. Der kann sogar verschlüsseln. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Feature. Also die haben noch so zwei, drei In-App-Purchases. Es gibt ja so verschlüsselte Zip-Tralala, das kann das alles. Sie können auch ordentlich pushen. Also mein Ding ist dauerhaft eingebucht, zum Beispiel einer meiner Zipgate-Accounts ist dauerhaft eingebucht. Aber mein Telefon nuckelt sich da nicht leer, weil die haben so einen Push-Server. Und wenn mich dann jemand auf der Zipgate nochmal anruft, dann wird der per Push geweckt und lalala. Das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. So gut es halt geht auf dem iOS, was ich da immer wieder rausschmeiße aus dem Speicher.
Okay, ist geschoppt. Ich werde das mal hier anregen.
Schämen Sie sich gar nicht mit dem Ladekabel da?
Ist doch der Name für solche Leute.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist total geklebt irgendwie mit schwarzen Zeug. Am Ende des Geklebten ist aber trotzdem alles auseinandergedröselt und kaputt und kommt dann noch Strom durch, oder?
Ja.
Und du hast keine Verlustwärme da irgendwie im Kabel und so.
Hab ich jetzt eben was empfohlen öffentlich? Scheiße. Aber ich benutze das und bin da recht zufrieden mit. Vor allem, weil ich spiele ja auch so rum. Das kann auch, warte mal, vor sechs ist noch nicht offiziell supported. Ich hab da so Sachen schon mit getestet, ist aber noch nicht offiziell supported. Die machen auch immer noch regelmäßig Software-Updates dafür. Der hat fünf verschiedene Modi, wie du eingehende Cords behandeln kannst. Und das Problem, wie wir alle wissen, das ist euch jetzt nicht ein Problem von Acrobit oder von dem Groundwire, sondern das Problem ist, dass der Apple dich einfach gnadenlos aus dem Speicher schmeißt, wenn du nichts tust. Du darfst dich halt registrieren für bestimmte Sachen, aber du darfst dich nicht dafür registrieren, dass du sagst, ich möchte ja gerne mal ein SIP-Paket haben oder sowas. Vielleicht geht das auch, aber das Problem ist, du wechselst mit deinem Telefon dauernd immer die Dinger, deine Zugänge und damit SIP funktioniert. Nochmal, wir reden jetzt über eingehende SIP-Cords. Du kannst einfach sagen, I don't care für eingehende SIP-Cords, ich mach mit dem Ding nur abgehende SIP-Cords gegen meinen Studio Link und dann ist der Drops auch hier lustig. Abgehende SIP-Cords sind in der Regel kein Problem. Um eingehende SIP-Cords zu empfangen, musst du dich bei einem Registrar registrieren. Du musst dein Gerät sagen, ich bin der und der Account mit der und der Rufnummer und hier ist gerade meine aktuelle IP-Adresse und wenn jetzt ein eingehender Ruf kommt, sag mir doch mal unter dieser IP-Adresse Bescheid. Und das kostet halt unglaublich viel Batterie und deswegen lässt dir Apple sowas auch nicht zu, sondern schmeißt dich raus. Und was die dann machen ist, das ist natürlich schon Security, wie auch immer, du kannst über die App, deine Einstellung, deinen Account, den du hast, sagen wir mal bei Zipgate, kannst du temporär übertragen, wenn du jetzt nicht online bist, überträgt die Abdehnung auf den Push-Server von Acrobits. Das heißt, der eingehende Call landet bei denen, die schicken über den Push-Mechanismus, wecken die ihre App, also über den Apple-Push-Mechanismus wecken die ihre App und dann wird der Call wieder übergeben an deine App. Das bedeutet aber, dass in der Zwischenzeit sozusagen der Acrobits-Server bei denen in Tschechien sich bei Zipgate anmeldet, für dich. Du kannst das auch im Background machen. Du kannst diese App, wie gesagt, 4 oder 5 verschiedene Modi für eingehende Calls. Es gibt auch diese Background-Mechanismus. Der geht auch. Allerdings immer wieder Ärger. Dein Maul zit dich an wie so häufig kann ich keine Keepalive-Pakete senden, und iOS schmeißt mich raus und hin und her. Also ist das iOS relativ beastig für so Applikationen, die dauerhaft im Hintergrund liegen wollen. Das mögen die nicht so gerne.
Aber man kann ja auch mit mehreren Sips haben.
Und wenn du, wie gesagt, E-Blues aus dem Ding raus deinen Studio Link anrufen willst, machst du E-Blues Outbound Chords und dann ist das gar kein Thema. Gar kein Thema. Man kann ja auch unterschiedliche Codecs einstellen, je nachdem ob du jetzt im LTE bist oder im WLAN und so. Kannst du sagen, ja LTE mach ich zwar Opus, aber nicht Whiteband oder so. Kannst du all das machen.
Ja, also das wär natürlich jetzt super, wenn das gehen würde. Ich meine, dann bräuchte ich ja hier nur meinen, bräuchte ich sozusagen Zugang bei Studio Link. Da kann ich mich ja auch...
Denken die betreiben, betreiben die auch einen eigenen Zip-Server? Achso, aber ohne Telefonieanbindung?
Ohne Telefonieanbindung, genau. Aber darüber kannst du dann halt vermitteln. Also das ist halt das Coole. Du musst halt nicht noch einen Zip-Account eintragen. Du startest das Ding und es registriert sich automatisch, dynamisch in einen Account.
Wenn du die Codex testen willst, versuchst du erst mal nur in abgehender Richtung, weil das ist sozusagen einfach, von den ganzen Protokoll-Dingern her. Und wenn das ordentlich läuft, dann versuchst du das so hinzupuzzeln, dass das auch für die eingehenden Accounts geht. Und dann hast du den Drops gelutscht.
Den Drops gelutscht.
So, während du da gerade deine Sippe konnt eintippst, du hast auch vorhin einen Hörer gegrüßt, der dir was geschenkt hat. Ich grüße jetzt mal den Schwager von einer Tänzerin, die mich gestern bei einer Tanzveranstaltung angesprochen hat. Deren Namen ich jetzt nicht parat habe, aber die meinen Namen irgendwie parat hatte, meint er dann so, du bist der Clemens, der jetzt auch Rom-Podcasts und ich so, naja, kommt mal vorgelegentlich. Wieso denn? Habe ich denn jetzt hier eine Hörerin? Nein, aber irgendwie ihr Schwager wisse ja, dass sie tanzt, Lindy Hop tanzt und der hat es hier gehört und der hört uns und den grüße ich jetzt mal zurück. Nur so aus Spaß, because I can. Und weil jetzt Tim gerade Blödsinn getippt hat auf seinem Rechner. So, danke, habe ich jetzt sie grüßt.
Grüße, grüß dich.
Grüß dich, Paweł.
Und wollen wir jetzt noch ein großes Thema aufmachen?
Shining in YouTube 360 ist ja auch gut.
Na, wir haben ja noch eine dreiviertel Stunde. Wir machen ja heute noch eine kurze Sendung.
Wieso machen wir eigentlich kurze Sendung? Du hast Early Expiry of Your Babysitter oder was? Nö, das war seine Ansage.
Ach echt, ja?
Weil ihm der Babysitter expired um 11.
Es kam auch dem Gast entgegen, der es ja dann am Ende doch nicht geschafft hat, in dieser Sendung, von daher...
Na ja, also ich beschwere mich nicht.
Schönes nettes Nerd-Thema, bevor wir wieder abdriften. Es ist ja schon seit Jahren diese Jaguaskript-Fuzzies. Die haben auch nichts besseres zu tun.
Was für ein Skript?
Ja, die müssen ja allen möglichen Dreck in Jaguaskript zu implementieren, just to show that they can. So, dass man jetzt auf dem Webbrowser mal einen Taschenrechner programmiert, ist ja nun schon eher so... Man kann es sich auch ein bisschen schwerer machen. Man kann zum Beispiel hingehen, sagen, ich emuliere jetzt sozusagen den Microcode von einem alten HP-Taschenrechner, nämlich von einem HP 35. Suchen wir denn irgendjemanden, der da mal vor 30 Jahren mal das ROM ausgelesen hat und lasst dann mein JavaScript in meinem Browser diesen original ROM-Code von dem HP 35 implementieren. Warum weiß keine Sau? HP 35 ist was? Klickt doch mal HP 35, das ist so ein berühmter alter Taschenrechner. Mit so einer roten LED-Anzeige. Richtig, aber so schön UPN, umgekehrte polnische Notation. So mit Stack und Enter und so, sehr schick. Hat auch Spaß gemacht immer. Nee, das war später, das war ja Dingenskirchen. Das waren ja die Japaner. Wie hießen die noch gleich? Casio. Casio hat doch diese musikmachenden Taschenrechner rausgebracht. Oder die rechnenden Elektronik-Plastikklaviere. Jedenfalls, der HP 35 hat nie Musik gemacht. Oder sehr leise? Am Ende des Tages haben sie wieder einen Taschenrechner im Browser. Den aber mit dem Original Bugs eines HP 35. Der hat sich nämlich damals bei bestimmten Logarithmen und so etwas verrechnet. Das ist jetzt ganz toll. Aber das ist schick gemacht. Dann siehst du den auch so im Original da. Dann haben sie das auch so gemacht, dass man sich das als iPhone-Ding in sein Homescreen legen kann. Ich habe also jetzt hier einen HP 35, der mit originalem Microcode JavaScript emuliert. So sieht der aus. Da guckst du hier. So eine Gründe ist das noch. Der kann jetzt alles inklusive sich original zu verrechnen. In meinem Browser, auf meinem iPhone, in JavaScript.
Ich habe damals schon mal Taschenrechner gebenchmarkt. Und zwar habe ich die Fakultät von 69 ausrechnen lassen. Und das hat halt gedauert. Und dann konntest du beide gleichzeitig starten und konntest richtig zugucken, welcher von beiden als erster fertig ist. Weil es hat schon so ein paar Sekunden gedauert, Fakultät 69. Das ging dann irgendwann nicht mehr, weil da war die tatsächlich. Du hast gedrückt und es war da. Aber die damals so, Mitte der 80er und ein bisschen später, da konntest du echt ein paar Sekunden warten, bis das Ergebnis kam.
Wann ist der raus?
72.
So, und die haben dann, aber echt, da muss man sich jetzt mal überlegen. Man emuliert jetzt diese CPU von dem Ding in JavaScript, nimmt einen olle Drum von dem Originalteil, jagtet darin, damit du einen Taschenrechner im Browser hast.
Die Bugs auch gefixt dann?
Nein, eben nicht, eben nicht. Die haben die Original Bugs von dem Ding mit übernommen natürlich.
Ja, das ist ja erstmal klar, aber dass sich dann einer hinsetzt und jetzt sozusagen das andere schon den Simulator hat, sich das nochmal anguckt und wo die Bugs sind und die dann fixt.
Es gibt wohl mehrere ROM-Versionen. Es gibt wohl später nochmal eine ROM-Version 4, die HP nochmal nachgeschoben hat. Natürlich. Ich finde es schon okay, ne? Because they can. Vor allen Dingen hast du den Taschenrechner am Browser, der voll das geile Feature ist, das braucht mir ja schon lange, der denn, wie gesagt, ein UPN ist, was heutzutage sowieso keine Sau mehr bedienen kann. Weißt du noch, was das ist, Huckel?
Außer den Force-Pro.
Ich weiß, was das ist, aber ich hab's nie benutzt.
Ja, umgekehrt polnische Notation.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich weiß, was das ist.
3, 4 plus.
Ja, nicht 3 plus 4 gleich oder so, sondern 3, 4 plus. Ja, gibt's zumindest immer noch nur so für die Linux oder Unix-Nerds. Auch mein beliebter Taschenrechner immer wieder auf den Linux oder Unix-Systemen ist DC.
Aber da gab's dann eine Enter-Taste, weil 3, 4 wäre dann 34. Also muss ja zwischen 3 und 4 noch eine andere Tasse gedrückt werden, oder?
Naja, ein Space, weil du jetzt damit nicht 34 draus machst. Ja, 3, Enter, 4 plus, genau.
Stehe.
Und in DC machst du das mit einem Space-Zeichen. Du machst da 3, Space, 4 plus. Das interessante an DC ist, dass der mit beliebig hoher Genauigkeit rechnen kann und beliebig große Zahlen kann. Deswegen benutze ich den immer ganz gerne. Und der kann schön konvertieren in andere Zahlensysteme. Also Binea und Hex und lalalala und so kann er auch alles.
Ich hab ja schon seit Jahren bei Ebay einen Search-Begriff auf meinen Sharp EL512S, aber gibt's da noch nicht mehr.
Nee, ich möchte gerne einen HP 45 haben. Hieß der 45? Wer emuliert mir den?
Ich hab ja vor ein paar Tagen eine Lokbrunnenz-Politik aufgenommen mit...
Mit Taschenrechner.
Mit Linus. Und es gab ja gerade dieses Sampling-Urteil vom Verfassungsgericht.
Mit Kraftwerk und so.
Mit Kraftwerk und diesem...
Wie war dieser Kommentar in der Zeitung? Leute, die seit 30 Jahren nichts geschafft haben, klagen gegen einen, der noch nie was geschafft hat.
Kann man so sehen. Und in den Kommentaren kam dann irgendwie jemand und meinte so, ja, was habt ihr denn immer so mit eurem Kraftwerk und so? Oder über Twitter. Dann wurde mir so klar so, ah...
Kein Schwein.
Es gibt Leute, also kein Schwein. Wenn man sich mit Musik, Geschichte, auch nur ansatzweise beschäftigt, muss einem Kraftwerk geläufig sein. Aber unser Selbstverständnis, ich meine unsere Generation, also auch eure, meine sowieso, ist so nachhaltig von dieser Band geprägt worden, dass es vielleicht an dieser Stelle auch noch mal wichtig ist, darauf hinzuweisen. Also Leute, wenn ihr keine Ahnung habt, was Kraftwerk ist, kann man das fast kaum vorstellen, aber dann bitte, hört euch das alles an.
Unter anderem gibt es Taschenrechner.
Ja stimmt, ist ein geiler Song.
Ich bin der Musikant mit Taschenrechner in der Hand. Ich addiere, genau, das gibt es ja auch auf Englisch, ich addiere und subtrahiere, kontrolliere und komponiere. Und wenn ich diese Taste drücke, spielt er ein kleines Musikstück. Ich war mal auf einem Kraftwerk-Konzert und die Jungs sind ja so knallerhart, die reden ja auch nicht mit einem. Also die kommen irgendwie alle auf die Bühne, einer nach dem anderen, sagen keinen Ton, bringen da irgendwie ihre Geräte an den Start und dann wird erstmal so eine Viertelstunde lang einfach Musik eins nach dem anderen, immer alles so perfekt, so im ganzen Timing und alles, Pipa Pro, Video, alles perfekt, aber sie reden halt irgendwie nicht mit einem. Aber dann, beim Taschenrechner, hatten sie irgendwie so ein bolides Device mit so einem fetten Kabel dran, was so ein bisschen eher wie so eine Fernsteuerung für so ein Industrie-Fahrstuhl aus den 80ern aussah, ja, also so ein fettes Gerät, was sie dann irgendwie ins Publikum reichten, eben mit diesem, wenn ich diese Taste drücke, spiele ich ein kleines Musikstück und dann durften halt die Leute da in der ersten Reihe auf die Taste drücke, woraufhin ein kleines Musikstück erntönte und das war dann sozusagen der erste Moment, wo hat man natürlich auf seinem iPhone. Genau, hat man auf seinem iPhone. Das war so der erste Moment, wo dann mal jemand überhaupt zu einem sprach. Und er nahm halt dieses Gerät wieder zurück, nachdem die Zuschauerschaft da drauf rumgedrückt hat und sagte, jeder kann elektronische Musik machen. Das war dann bis zum Ende des Konzertes der einzige vokale Beitrag, der nicht gesungenes Lied war. Und ja, am Schluss sagten sie noch, guten Abend. Das war alles, das war die komplette vokale Inhalt. Und ich weiß ja, ich hab das nie vergessen, weil sie waren halt diejenigen, die das damals alles losgetreten haben. Ich meine, sie waren nicht die einzigen Pioniere der elektronischen Musik, das will ich nicht sagen. Aber sie haben, finde ich, nicht nur den Zeitgeist gut getroffen, Autobahn und so, sondern sie haben auch es geschafft, Melodien zu schaffen, die trotz ihrer Minimalität, also die nicht darauf angewiesen waren, dass sie mit Gitarren und Verbe und voller Stimme gesungen wurden, sondern die einfach nur so lose vor sich hin klimpern konnten auf frühen Synthesizers und trotzdem bis heute noch vollkommen erhalten sind. Insofern kann ich so ein bisschen nachvollziehen, warum sie auch nach 30 Jahren dann auch so hinterherklagen, weil die, es ging ja um Metall auf Metall an der Stelle, die stehen einfach total auf ihre Rhythmen. Also sie wissen, dass ihr Beitrag zu der Musikgeschichte so essentiell ist, also mit den Rhythmen und ihren Melodien, finde ich, haben sie sehr viel mehr hinterlassen als viele andere mit ihren Rhythmen und Melodien, wenn man vielleicht mal vom Armenbreak absieht. Damals war es.
Die hatten auch noch so ein paar andere schöne Zeilen noch gelegt.
Die haben eigentlich nur schöne Zeilen gehabt. Also es war alles total klar und total...
Und das war lange vor der dämlichen neuen deutschen Welle.
Ja natürlich. Wir fahren, fahren, fahren auf der Autobahn. Vor uns liegt ein weites Tal. Die Sonne scheint mit Glitzerstrahl. Die Fahrbahn ist ein graues Band, weiße Streifen, grüner Rand. Jetzt schalten wir ja das Radio an. Aus dem Lautsprecher klingt es dann Wir fahren, fahren, fahren auf der Autobahn. Und das ist der ganze Text. Mehr muss man dazu irgendwie auch nicht sagen. Oder um es nochmal gleich zu toppen.
Computerliebe.
Ich bin allein, mal wieder ganz allein. Starre auf den Fernsehschirm. Hab heut Nacht nichts zu tun. Hab heut Nacht nichts zu tun. Ich brauch ein Rendezvous. Erstmal brauchen wir einen Echo-Canceler. Ich wähl die Nummer, rufe Bildschirmtext.
Rufe Bildschirmtext.
Hab heut Nacht nichts zu tun. Ich brauch ein Rendezvous.
Rap your dick in double click. Das ist auch schon grandios. Da war vielleicht noch, wen für die Jury, die das nicht wissen. The Internet was made for porn. Kann man mal nach googeln. Ist ein sehr, sehr nettes Video. Auch nicht die Variante, wo du an welche komischen Schauspieler auf der Bühne rumhüpfen, sondern die Variante, die mit WoW Charaktern, also World of Warcraft Charakter gemacht ist, die sollte man auch dazusehen. Also HP-Taschenrechner, altes Zeugs. Was hab ich denn noch? Ach ja, darf ich mich noch mal ganz kurz mal wieder über Application-Sizes beschweren? Das hilft natürlich nichts, wenn Roddy nicht hier ist. Aber vielleicht hören wir dazu zu der nächsten WWDC noch mal was. Gelegentlich gucke ich ja mal drauf, was mir mein iPhone so an Updates vorschlägt. Und dann hat man ja so kleine Kröten-Ups drauf, die so irgendeinen Blödsinn machen jetzt ohne viel Display oder sonst irgendwas. Und dann steht da so, ja, neuer Update, Performance Improvements, 119 Megabyte. Jede Drecks-Up ist inzwischen in diesem Range von 70, 100 und mehr. Das liegt jetzt gar nicht daran, dass die so wie so ein Kartendienst oder so, was jetzt noch Kartenmaterial mitbringen, sondern das ist nur eine dumme App. Aber wie gesagt, da müssen wir jetzt mal so einen App-Developer fragen. War da nicht mal was, dass Apple mit großem Bombonium das eingeführt hat, dass jetzt diese App-Thinning, dass der App-Store das mal rossortiert, dass sie nicht für das iPod Retina Pro, Lalala, da jetzt wie die Images mit reinladen.
Dass sie auch nicht nachladen können und dass du auch nur das kriegst, was für deine Plattform genutzt wird, also nur die 64-Bit-Teile und so weiter.
Und was ist da draus geworden?
Und auch nur die Bilder der Resolution, wie dein Gerät ist und so.
Ist das alles wieder in der Versenkung verschbunden?
Ich werde einfach alles mitmachen und das kostet natürlich Arbeit. Und diese ganzen El-Gpo-Programme, die machen das einfach nicht, weil es kostet ja Zeit und Arbeit.
Ja, aber auch nicht El-Gpo-Programme brauchen Terrabits da.
Aber ich glaube, da musst du dich bei den App-Developern beschweren und nicht bei Apple.
Ich glaube, Apple hat das gar nicht ausgerollt. Die doktorieren zwar den Developern auf, dass die ihre App so einstellen müssen, aber so wird das nicht ausgeliefert. Das sehe ich jedenfalls nicht.
Ich würde sagen, du musst dich bei den App-Developern beschweren.
Deswegen, wo ist der Roddy, wenn man ihn braucht?
Du musst dich da bei dem...
Den kann man bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen mal kicken, ob das auch 120 MB braucht.
Aber du kannst mal hier über deine neue iPhone-Hülle erzählen.
Das ist keine neue iPhone-Hülle. Das ist einfach nur, weil ich jetzt so unglaublich viel telefoniere, jetzt den ganzen Tag unterwegs bin. Und nicht dazu komme... Jetzt gerade bei dem schönen Wetter laufe ich ja auch viel und so. Und fahre nicht da immer mit meinem großen Ladegerät rum. Da, drücken, drücken und halten. So, siehst du den Batterieglieder.
Ach so, denn man muss extra einschalten.
Genau. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt eine Hülle, die so eine Bakterie hinten dran hat.
Sieht aber recht schmal aus, oder?
Ist auch... Ist auch...
Geht eigentlich.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Ach, das ist ja schwer wie ein Sieg.
Ja, aber hat wahrscheinlich nochmal doppelt so viel Saft drin.
Wie heißt das Ding? Anker. Das ist von Anker so eine Hülle für 6S. Ja, hat mir jetzt schon ein paar Mal den Arsch gerettet. Arsch retten ist wie teuer. Das fragt mich, keine Ahnung. Habe ich letztes Jahr einfach mal dazu geklickt. Wie für das Ding. Gibt es schon eine ganze Weile. Ist von Anker eine Scheißkugel.
Hülle.
Anker iPhone 6, Ultradünnes Akkuschacht.
Ich merke mir doch jetzt nicht, für jede Scheiß USB-Kabel, die ich überhaupt habe.
Hat doch mal 3.100 mAh, also noch zweimal so viel fast wie das iPhone hat.
40 Euro?
Batterie, SafePack oder Blah.
Also meine Lederhülle, die nichts kann, war teurer.
Okay, kann man machen.
Gibt es auch eine kleine Version, die 70 Euro kostet? Hä? Wie jetzt? Was lese ich falsch?
Ich suche jetzt sofort in meinem…
Die kleine Version kostet 70 Euro, die große Kostet 39 Euro. Rechnen 5, 6?
Hab ich damals mal, brauch ich jetzt schnell, wie bei Amazon geklickt, muss ich jetzt in meine Amazon-Bestellung gucken, was das Ding kostet hat. Aber war vertretbar, deswegen hab ich mir das... Ja, und wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt so zu Fuß unterwegs ist und so, also ohne großes Ladegerät, dann... Wenn ich mit dem Auto unterwegs bin, steckst du immer da in die Haltung, dann lädt es während ich unterwegs bin.
Ja, wie viele Zyklen kriegt denn das Ding so noch zusätzlich?
1,5 ungefähr. Also von dem 6S. Wenn das 6S richtig runter hinnuckelt ist, kann ich es nochmal voll laden und hab dann immer nochmal, ja kann man.
Ein Tag, ich muss das auch nochmal heben.
Wie gesagt, die meinen das Ding hat 3.100 mAh, das 6S hat glaube ich 1.600 mAh an Batterie. Was da ein bisschen Übertragungsverlust und so, weil die müssen ja auf 5 Volt hoch und runter wandeln, glaube ich. Bin mir jetzt aber nicht so sicher, vielleicht geht das auch direkt, aber ein bisschen Verlust hast du immer.
Was ganz nett ist, ich mag ja dieses Ankerzeug, auch wie wir alle eigentlich so, ne. Und sie haben sogar an das Thema gedacht, dass guck mal, jetzt hast du hier unten, dadurch dass das Gehäuse größer wird, ist jetzt der Kopfhöreranschluss weiter weg vom Telefon. Und sie liefern extra noch so einen Adapter mit, wenn du jetzt einen Stöpsel hast, der nicht lang genug ist dafür, dann kannst du da noch einen Adapter reinmachen, dass du dann deinen Kopfhörer wieder ranstecken kannst. Es ist halt so ankermäßig, finde ich, das ist halt ganz gut zu starten. Ja, ich mag das ganz gerne.
Gibt es das auch fürs iPhone 5? Na es ist eh halt.
Ah, stimmt.
Das ist ja gleichwertig. Ich bin aber jetzt sehr zufrieden. Nee, gibt's nicht.
Also suche auch nach ohne SE, weil die Hülle ist ja die gleiche. Also kannst du auch nach dem 5er suchen, ob es für das 5er so einen Pack gibt.
Ja, suche ich gerade, gibt's aber glaube ich nicht.
Okay, 5er Formfaktor. Ich bin neulich mal danach gefragt worden innerhalb der Familie und da habe ich den nur bei Apple geklickt, da war so Lieferzeiten so an und tuff.
Absurd, die Nachfrage scheint extrem hoch zu sein. Oder Apple hat sich vollkommen verkalkuliert oder beides.
Und das ist auch rechts unten.
Das hat im Prinzip dieselben Specks. Na, es hat nicht die 128, du kriegst es nur in 64. Aber es ist halt einfach ein kompakt kleines Phone. Mit einem Finger überall ran. Das ist einfach das Telefon.
Ich bin mit dem 6S sehr zufrieden. Da komme ich auch noch alles dran. Es gibt Kollegen von mir, da gerade im ITF-Umfeld, die rennen alle mit 6S Plus rum oder so. Also mit diesen Stullenbrettern. Dann wäre mir nichts.
Na, für mich ist das 6S schon ein Stullenbrett. Aber jeder wie er mag. So viel zum iPhone-Akku.
Jetzt mal wieder ein Spaß-Thema. Machen wir hier Shining on YouTube.
YouTube 360.
Ich hätte auch noch was zum Thema Dating.
Was ist das Ding da jetzt?
Nur mal so als Entertainment-Moment.
Warte mal.
Ist das auch was zum Hören?
Eigentlich schon.
Wenn wir denn eine Audiospur haben?
Ich muss mal kurz...
Eigentlich sollte das...
Wir sehen zwei Leute, ein Mann, eine Frau auf einer Couch, die auf ihren Apple Laptops umtippen.
See you then!
Weiß-Space.
Weil es auf anderen Computern anders aussehen könnte. Ich bin eine Kompressoren-Kompanie, ich habe mein Leben um Minimalisierung von Filesize gewonnen.
Wir bringen Kinder in diese Welt mit dem Kopf über den Kopf? Und schau mal, das wird jetzt nie passieren, weil ich nicht mit jemandem sein werde, der Spaces über Tabs benutzt.
Ich würde sie auch nicht daten, das geht gar nicht. Nee, aber ich bin Tab-User.
Ich bin auch Tab-User, aber ich benutze Wim.
Ich auch.
Ich dachte früher, dass Tabs auch die reine Leere sind, aber mittlerweile ist das alles Quatsch. Das ist einfach ein reines Tool-Problem. Tabs sind im Prinzip der falsche Weg.
Aber ich bin das Tool und ich brauch Tabs.
Tabs sind semantisch sicherlich ganz interessant. Das ist noch sehr formuliert. Ja, aber das ist dann auch alles. Das ist im Prinzip nur ein zugekniffener Po. Das ist einfach, wenn man einfach da...
Viel schlimmer finde ich ja die Leute, die im Wim TS-4 einstellen. Der Wim aus dem Tab 4 Space macht das geht gar nicht.
Das hab ich.
Das war's, die Freak Show.
Tab Expansion, natürlich. Anlass kann man das doch nicht benutzen.
Aber mit dem Wim... Ich hatte gerade heute das Erlebnis, dass ich jemanden...
In der ganzen Firma ist Konvention, dass keine Tabs verwendet werden.
Ich hab heute jemanden Wim-Commandos in die Tastatur... diktieren müssen. Und dann so nach 10 Minuten reichte mich... noch ein ziemlich konstantierter Blick. Weil ich immer so sagte, so KKKKCW, Blafasel-Laber, Escape, Doppelpunkt-Prozent-S. Und die Augen wurden immer größer. Erst dann fühlte ich mich nicht auf, weil mir fließt das ja aus Muscle-Memory, weil ich das schon eine Weile mache. Und dann auch so, ja okay, also für 2016 vielleicht doch ein bisschen anachrussisch, aber es trotzdem irgendwie so.
Ja, wenn man so ein Ohnfahrt ist, ist das irgendwie schon ganz lustig. Also ich kam zum Beispiel am Anfang mit Vim nicht klar, weil der war halt nicht wirklich kompatibel zu VI.
Da haben sie so in den Arsch getreten.
Alle sagen irgendwie immer Vim, und für mich war das so modernes Zeug. Also es musste sich schon verhalten wie VI.
Aber ist doch total kompatibel.
Nein, das ist nicht. Ich spüre das.
This is no Jim Beam, oder?
Genau, so ist es.
Mittlerweile ist mir das ehrlich gesagt auch alles ziemlich egal. Man muss ja auch ein bisschen mit der Zeit gehen, ne? Da kann man dann auch mal Spaces benutzen. Nee, ich meine, das ist ja eine Tool-Frage. Früher gab es halt für sowas wie Einrücken einfach keine Tools, aber mit den modernen Editoren ist das alles Quatsch.
Das brauch ich auch nicht. Ich hab Tabs, da brauch ich keinen, der für mich einrückt, weil das geht schneller als der, der das da macht. Das bringt mich nur durcheinander.
Wieso denn? Wenn du deine Tab-Expansion an hast, drückst du genauso Tab und dann sind wir Spaces, du siehst gar nicht den Unterschied.
Ich fahre aber mit dem Cursor in meinem Brot rum und wenn der dann bei den Spaces jeden Dings einzumacht, das nervt mich.
Intelligenz, ja, aber hast du wahrscheinlich nicht. Dafür sieht es auf jedem Computer gleich aus. Das ist der große Vorteil.
Das ist mir doch egal, wenn das an andere Leute geht.
Genau, das war nämlich der Punkt.
Dann schieben die das doch eh durch den Re-Indentor.
Durch den Re-Indentor und dann das Ruhr.
Den Re-Indentor. Also die epische Diskussion, die können wir ja nächste Mal führen. Wenn wir alle noch frisch im Saft stehen, dann gibt es ja den Battle of Taps vs. Bases.
NVI vs. Emacs. Wir haben ja keinen Contestant für die Emacs-Seite, ne?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich habe früher mal Emacs benutzt, aber der war mir zu viele Klammern.
Was ich ganz, ganz, ganz früher benutzt habe, war Micro Emacs. Gab es ja auch noch mal so ein Ding. Das war aber so auch schon für Ewigkeiten. Aber jetzt, ja, Emacs waren mir zu viele Klammern, genau. Wenn jetzt Hans Fübner hier wäre, der würde uns was erzählen, warum die ganzen Klammern da so unglaublich wichtig sind in dem Lisp.
Tja, das ist nochmal eine andere Frage, aber...
Genau, machen wir jetzt als Absacker einmal Shining.
Ja, das spiele ich aber jetzt nicht, weil das macht keinen Sinn. Das ist nur ein Hinweis. Also da hat jemand... Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch hat das überhaupt eingetragen?
Hab ich das eingetragen?
Da hat jemand dieses Shining-Haus nachgemacht und gezeigt, dass das von den Räumen gar nicht geht.
Ach, ich hab das eingetragen. Also das ist sozusagen Shining... Also die haben den Film genommen und haben quasi von dem Filmmaterial... Äh, kurz verhindern, dass das hier abspielt, weil das macht jetzt für die Zuhörer keinen Sinn. Aber um euch das nochmal ein bisschen kurz zu verdeutlichen, also das nutzt schlicht diese 360°-Video-Funktion von YouTube, die ich ja ziemlich bemerkenswert finde. Also man kann ja heutzutage 360°-Videos machen. Also du kannst mit mehreren Kameras rundherum überall parallel filmen und es gibt dann Werkzeuge, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das macht. Es geht auf jeden Fall, dass du quasi den Film nicht mehr als Quadrat ablieferst, sondern eben als Kugel.
Hast du immer auf dem iPhone abgespielt? Diese 360°-Videos? Mach das mal.
Und, was ist dann?
Mach mal. Nimm mal dein YouTube-Kleinspiel mal. Geht oder geht nicht? Doch, geht super. Geht super rarer als überall woanders noch. Du nutzt ja nämlich auf dem iPhone die Orientierung von deinem Telefon. Du hast dein Telefon in der Hand, wenn du halt links gucken willst, drisst es einfach nach links.
Sehr cool. Und ich glaube, da ist eine Menge Musik drin und da ist Google echt weit vorne. So, jetzt ist natürlich Shining ein Film, der nicht in 3D gedreht wurde.
In 360°.
In 360° gedreht wurde und auch nicht in 3D. Und was sie aber jetzt gemacht haben, ist, sie haben sozusagen in dem Film alle Kameraschwenks so mitgenommen, dass sie daraus einen 360° Film gemacht haben.
Den ganzen Film?
Nein, das ist 30 Minuten.
Das ist nicht der ganze Film. Ja, aber ich kann das mal hier kurz für euch starten. Das ist dann sozusagen nicht vollständig, aber am Anfang sind halt so Flüge. Und du kannst dann halt diese Initialsequenz im Prinzip aus jeder Perspektive machen, die in irgendeiner Form zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt in dem Film mal eingenommen wurde. Das ist natürlich nicht vollständig, aber es ist ziemlich vollständig. Auf dem iPhone sieht es auch geil aus. Safari läuft nicht, es läuft nur auf Chrome, aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass die...
Machst du auf dem YouTube-Klient auf dem iPhone, macht viel mehr Spaß. Den kannst du jetzt auch an diesen Cardboard-Modus versetzen. Das heißt, da gibst du so einen Softbutton, da kannst du draufdrücken, schiebst dir das Ding in diese Google-Cardboard-Dingsen rein. Dann setzt du das auf, dann hast du das selbe. Diesen 360-Effekt nochmal in 3D zusätzlich.
Also es ist wirklich geil, weil man sieht, Shining mag jetzt nicht so sehr viel hergeben, aber mit dieser Technik, über die ich jetzt gar nicht so viel gelesen habe, kann man ja im Prinzip von jedem seriellen Film, der irgendeine Umgebung filmt, dann sozusagen daraus ein 360-Grad-Modell machen und dann entsprechend, also das kann man ja eh schon, aber das sozusagen dann auch gleich in so einem Film umsetzen. Schon ziemlich cool. Ja, das ist eigentlich schon alles, was man dazu sagen kann. Ist eine schöne Technologie.
Aber wahrscheinlich schon genau der richtige Film dafür, weil es da ganz viele Kamerafahrten durch dieses Haus gibt.
Genau, weil es einfach sehr viele von diesen Flugsequenzen gibt, die relativ lange halten etc. Ja, das ist schon irgendwie ganz, ganz geil so. Und ich denke, das wird jetzt auch nicht mehr so lange dauern. Da ist wahrscheinlich schon längst so weit, dass du halt fertige Mount-Kits für deine GoPro... Also gibt es jetzt schon und ich weiß bloß nicht, was das kostet.
Da sitzen ja 12 GoPros drauf oder so, oder 8 oder so. Ich weiß nicht.
Weitere eine mit so einem runden Spiegel, so eine Spiegelkugel.
Das gibt es auch, das habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Die machen das eher mit mehreren Kameras.
Du leidest doch an der Verlösung.
Ja, wenn, dann willst du auch ordentlich 4K-Klimpen in jede Richtung haben.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch so chinesische GoPro-Klons. So Xingchang Shun für irgendwie schmales Geld, die eben auch so Full HD oder schlimmer oder so was aufnehmen. Für irgendwie zweistellig Euro oder klein dreistellig.
So, das nur dazu.
Und jetzt? Jetzt gehen wir heim.
Jetzt wollen sie Bluetooth und Bose. Wieso haben wir noch 12 Minuten? Jetzt gehen wir mal Bluetooth und Bose. Was ist hinter dir?
Bluetooth und Bose fielen mir etwas auf. Wir haben ja schon mehrfach diese Noise-Cancelling-Headsets hier erwähnt. Sowohl diese On-Ear als auch In-Ear-Dinger, die ich sehr gerne benutze, diese QuietComfort-Dinger. Und die 25. Und die anderen, die In-Ear... Egal, jedenfalls hat Bose davon...
On-Ear, In-Ear und Over-Ear sogar.
Hat Bose jetzt davon Bluetooth-Varianten vorgestellt, die auch wieder so mit mehreren Mikrofonen und lalalala, wie high and teuer, aber auch high and gut angeblich. Mal sehen, wenn so was mal im Laden auftaucht, werde ich es mal ausprobieren, dann sage ich mal was dazu. Was mich viel eher annerft, ich hatte es schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, vielleicht kann man hier nochmal ein bisschen Follower-Power nochmal aktivieren. Ich hätte wirklich gerne mal ein Bluetooth-Headset, was in der Lage ist, auch im Telefonie-Modus, also in dem Modus, wo man sein Mikrofon benutzt, nicht auf 3,1 Kilohertz zurückzuschalten. Dann hast du mal dieses Stereo-Headset, da kannst du super toll Musik drauf hören, alt schick, alt toll. Und wenn dich denn jemand anruft, oder selbst wenn du jetzt einen Skype- oder Facetime-Call hast, kriegst du wieder so diese Gequake von 1874. Ja, wir machen jetzt hier Telefonie und komponieren nicht alle 3,1 Kilohertz. Das kann Bluetooth und du kannst damit Skype-Calls machen. Sicher? Sicher? Probier mal aus. Weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das wäre.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, hab noch nicht so oft damit telefoniert, weil das Mikrofon ist nicht ganz so dolle. Also die andere Seite ist jetzt nicht so viel besser, als wenn ich das kleine Abfehlkabel nehme, das was dabei ist.
Die normalen Bluetooth-Headsets schalten aber sogar auf der höheren Seite runter. Also nicht, dass das Mikrofon nur für Telefonie-Design ist. Probier es mal aus mit Facetime oder mit Skype. Gut, frag mal bitte. Ich suche immer noch nach einem Bluetooth-Headset, was eben nicht diesen Effekt hat und was vielleicht sogar auch mein Mikrofon mit mehr als 3,1 Kilohertz überträgt. Weil wir haben jetzt 2016 und HD-Codecs all over the place und ich möchte jetzt gerne ein Headset haben, was das auch unterstützt.
Jetzt ist sogar Bluetooth 5 vorgestellt worden.
Und, macht jetzt was?
Da hatte ich leider nicht mehr die Zeit, das durchzulesen, weil es nur angekündigt wurde. Weil dann musste ich mich leider um andere Dinge kümmern und dann war irgendwann die Sendung.
Man verbraucht jetzt so wenig Energie, das erzeugt Energie, oder?
Gute Frage, gute Frage. Ich weiß noch mal, es ist angekündigt worden.
Gut, dann schmeiße ich jetzt noch einen Fuck-Up mit rein, den wir ja gerade in dieser Tage gesehen haben, hatte ich gestern auch getweetet. Netflix hat ja Anfang des Jahres angefangen, diese ganzen VPNs rauszubürsten, jedenfalls, die sie kennen. Und jetzt haben sie festgestellt, dass ihre Geolocation-Database für IPv6 auch scheiße ist. Es kommt jetzt häufiger vor, dass im IPv6-Bereich gibt es noch etliche Leute, die einen Tunnel benutzen, was für die Content-Mafia sehr aussieht wie ein VPN. Aber egal, jedenfalls hat sich Netflix jetzt entschlossen, auch da irgendwie vorzugehen. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt sehr viele User, denen Netflix nicht mehr geht. Und die Antwort von Netflix, was man denn da tun könnte, anstatt jetzt ihre Geodatabase in Ordnung zu bringen oder ihren Dienst ist, ja lieber User, dann schaltet doch bitte einfach IPv6 komplett ab in deinem Netz. Dann geht das auch wieder. Und das trägt mich dann doch ein bisschen auf. Wenn Netflix jetzt kein IPv6 richtig unterstützen will, dann sollen sie doch bitte schön das IPv6 aus ihrem eigenen DNS rausnehmen oder das auf ihrer Seite nicht mehr anbieten. Aber ich schalte doch nicht in meinem ganzen Netz jetzt IPv6 aus, komplett, überall in meinem Router und auf allen meinen Devices, nur damit das Drecks Netflix geht. Die haben ja nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank. Aber das ist dann so diese typische, diese Support-Anforderung, welche User ja, machen wir IPv6 aus.
Entschuldigung bitte.
Geht gar nicht.
War man nicht, oder doof?
Das betrifft zum Beispiel all die Leute, die HENet oder Sixtunnel oder so was benutzen auf ihrer Fritzbox. Also mal native IPv6, mit Telekom IPv6 geht's noch. Aber nur so mal als FY, warum jetzt euer Netflix seit gestern oder vorgestern noch umquakt.
So, ist das eigentlich hier die 178.
Und jetzt gehen wir heim.
Jetzt sind wir schon bei IPv6-Adoption bei Peak immer am Wochenende bei 12%. Wird langsam.
Es entwickelt sich, Genossenbauern.
Ja, ich hätte bloß trotzdem gerne hier immer irgendwie eine feste IPv6-Adresse, aber...
Warum?
Weil ich halt nicht in der Lage bin...
Feste IP-Adressen sind sowas von IPv4.
Ja, na dann sag mal, wie ich irgendwie so ein DNS-SD-Update irgendwie auf meine Domänen leicht einrichten kann.
Es gibt doch inzwischen jede Menge dünne DNS-Provider durch IPv6 können. Und die Fritzbox kann ich mir so ein Update, meine Fritzboxen. Das ist der tolle, geheime Trick. Wenn du...
Ja, die update dann nur ein Rekord für sich.
Ja, stimmt. Doch, den Präfix kann sie auch mit updaten. Muss ich mal raussuchen. Es gibt da so einen Hack.
Ich hab jetzt hier gerade mal meine Tunnel wieder ausgeschaltet, weil das ging halt irgendwie performancemäßig überhaupt nicht.
Ich mach's jetzt bei mir, ich nutze ja schon seit Jahren meinen eigenen Dünndehnen-Service, deswegen hab ich immer leicht reden, aber ich gucke mal, da gibt's auch eine offizielle Lösung, für die auch jeder mal draußen benutzen kann.
Das wäre mal wirklich interessant, weil ich will natürlich hier mein natives V6 auch richtig gut nutzen. Und brauche halt irgendwie Erreichbarkeit meiner Hosts und will halt nicht dieses bescheuerte Apple Back to my Mac, was in 50% der Fälle einfach versagt.
Du willst jetzt nur deine OS X Hosts hier erreichen, ja?
Genau, nur über V6.
Ja, ist okay, da schmeiß ich dir was über den Zaun für. Okay, aber jetzt darf ich nach Hause gehen.
Ja, wollen wir machen, wenn es das war.
Wir sind End of Thema.
Wir müssen heute leider ein bisschen früher Schluss machen, von daher nicht ganz so viel Inhaltsversorgung wie sonst. Und Huckel ist nicht so total genervt, der lächelt sogar noch. Das ist jetzt die Stunde, wo er normalerweise total degradiert. Und jetzt blickt er schon freudig. Nur einen Titel habe ich nicht für diese Sendung, müssen wir uns gleich noch was einfallen lassen.
Oh, hallo, Kind Monster!
Okie-dokie.
Oh? You're a pervert!
You're a pervert! You're a pervert!
You're a pervert! Send me that sweet online birthday card.